but by popular demand england's wolf of
wallstreet par three in the most popular
demand a podcast ever second to Emma
Kenny and no loves and party that it is
big enough so fun not really makes it
even more special
got the wild mind yeah the legendary
well so much about this book he's a
fictional characters you've heard some
you've heard almost constantly gone you
know these podcasts and he's heard
almost constantly get what man in the
pub but he's coming out of likewise he's
actually real the first podcast a lot of
people I imagine when you know what I
mean and then and then when you cease
really you're like 23 stall margin life
yeah you are me on you yeah you're one
of those characters like you walk in a
room and everyone's gonna [__] noise
I'd rather stand ugly so go in in of the
background you know exactly yeah sure so
plain it's just you know when everyone's
talking to us and it looks like on the
room really well I was like shining just
a little bit I was a teenage mom I just
like yeah it's like P Diddy and
notorious b.i.g so yeah so how do these
meet lots we could all together and
witness do disturb school kids want
something growing up you're three years
older than me and I was in a little gang
with his brothers who leader and his
cousin how me and they won't let Pete
you join and they used to beat him up
stuff his brother was cruel to him and
in the end I splintered off with Wellman
what made you think he was that better
option to hang out with at the time do
you remember we just don't like this
good connection we were like buzzing off
his boom box playing Bronski be hanging
out in the gay area of Manchester in
like the early that smooths it stuff
together and that lets were startin to
raves together didn't it well yeah we
like most of our mates of going to the
pubs in our lab we were jumping in the
soul but and we will go inside the sen
there and
to the raves and all what we just got
used to it
what just cuz these are names that a lot
of people don't know because they are
eight so told but things like that they
were massive rave places it's all a
little yeah so you go in your little toe
but to the Hacienda basically get into
this huge Club it opens out and bam
during the rave scene yeah well most
people are generation we're starting the
pops drinking you know fighting outside
nightclubs right we started doing that
early early age but didn't will leave
the hometown but me and while I'm alike
we're gonna get [__] out here and
explore so we go to the cities when we
live a pillow Manchester down to
Coventry yeah
but a famous places in that time cuz
Stoke and comment read out zone they
don't so he were huge right then
right convoys so thick on the motorway
you couldn't even you could see it from
that end that's what I like about the
rifts what was it in particular that got
in because when I got the places like
that it's like there's too many [__]
people everyone jump around you fit what
did you love about that alright well
back then fits half-naked birds for
so back then but that's music scene was
you went to a nightclub yes your shirt
and tie on bounces look down it yeah
maybe wouldn't even let you in kids were
sick of it all of a sudden they're
smashing up more houses
breaking into airplane hangars people
coming in with all this equipment a
frøydis illegal parties it was like a
revolution in music back then right all
over the news showing all these kids
with the big eyes on the ecstasy and the
police and the government were like oh
you know this is cerebral blah blah blah
what we're gonna do about these people
we were like we want a piece of that
well we refined the whole organized so
it's like literally you are cups
replaced it's like an old scrap yard and
then open the doors to guys there and
they've got like not big dogs and
they've got literally like as the bag so
you just throw you turn pound it because
back falls and morning and you think
dogs and when the police come did you
set the dogs on you just let the dogs go
and you just got it otherwise you're
gonna get your ass bit you know what I
mean
it was awesome little boys you know you
know you wonder if you're gonna get
arrested at the end of the night yeah
yeah I'm sick of doing the pub scene in
our buns for most of the Popes drama TV
fight was up being an [__] fighting
and then go into the nightclubs and then
always get kicked out night clubs and
the bouncers as always like chicken wing
meet Leah father and throw me out and
here's what [__] let's not fight
about you bastards see he's always
peeing and you're a sort of be a violent
man oh he's faced it no not really no
teeth marks on your knuckles through
there it's hard to look like they've had
a few
perfect for this pounding me when
zooming on to the room said if you got
that on the value engineering I like any
divorce so I've got a wife beside it
started in his school when he got bigger
than everybody than the and the teachers
put him outside raking the leaves the
teachers were so slower than him yeah
well basic what did the did was did I
think one of them's threatening me not
allowed to teach Cole mr. Hayes so I
fled to put a minute right right now
word the can seen it's the Japanese big
bins where they put all slop so I was
gonna throw in the slop so the the ABS
ghost of the headmaster and then if they
have masters late yet dislike traffic
waiting on his door were it was like red
weights no it was red
do not enter amber please way and green
going and I'm waiting to go and see that
master and they buy this suddenly Mormon
name which is like best friends first
name so it was every Friday should
download having a cup of tea what we're
gonna do is you our Peter or just give
him one more chance with you we're gonna
have to do something with him he's
really rampant blah blah blah and then
in the end I got kicked his door down to
the kept royal he kept me on red kept me
on night north dog go in so boosters
doll it just come off the hinges well I
didn't know it was nothing like his
stuff meeting and all the teachers with
her so I got suspended indefinitely for
that and what they did this has got me
private tutor from 9 o'clock 311 and I
just did English and math and then I
could go back home you know and after
six months they let me back in school
and I got into a fight with a couple of
guys and then that was it then you just
said well if you want to stay doing
exams you can help the kuretake you know
so that's what I did I helped the
kuretake you know but all of the kids
would go into the chippy getting the
chips I was going to the pub of the
house obviously curled LOC their bottles
all right I was going to the pub of
another lowest fee so I mean I think it
no qualifications I could I was well I
mean I knew a lot of the stuff but I
just I wasn't more surveyed so the class
clown
mmm as I and it wasn't really a lot
steiffel really light nothing is
actually motivate me I'm subject wise
yeah the havok disrupt the class I
rather be the class clown just be an
[__] really you two are in the same
school no no right okay so you can't
really you can't save right or wrong
about his experience but your experience
of him as a teenager is he someone who
is a bit of a firestarter in one sense
well we should probably tell you about
the red dots God let him sell you
besides get into the face with the
doorman and although I just use stuff
it's not Swiss red dots just a yeah but
you know like usually glaze over and
there's no a lot of people have a stop
like you stopping them do you know what
the guys happy enough but no I just like
glazed over help um all the shit's out
of him and pulling the [__] out of him
and someone getting direct off and the
whole favorite town once that services
got so much stretched core for like a be
a cheese and stuff like that and in the
end they start as Lutz like what I gots
like 16 17
she's gone clubs clubs are 16 I start
getting all this charge start getting
worse and worse and worse so sad the
stacking the debris instead to take a
pill and chill oh so that's what I did
in Italy did work you don't fight in
raves I mean later on it got Moody who
started game where you get gangsters
well wannabe gangsters coming and sauna
robbed pills and all that right but at
the very beginning it was just
refreshing it was nice there's no one in
your face there was no one like [__] you
trying to pick a fight or you know not
to prove anything no really we just took
a pill and add to life why do you think
people picked on you in the pub side or
did you feel that people picked on you
or do you think you sometimes went out
looking for a bit of a bit of both
really habitat both I did
we were looking for it too late but it
didn't necessarily go into public cars
of fight right but I'll end up like and
three honestly mobsters face I yet I
never really had many one-on-ones
there's always a couple from Charlotte
jump on me would you say had a
reputation so if someone saw you they'd
be like that's definitely orientation
yeah because even if two or three even
Tom me in the next week I'd pick them
off one by one I'll get bastards you
know really so you know how like you
said that you'd see the the range sort
of thing come over you yeah like for me
like I've got it a little bit of that
some days where when I lose it just it
all bets are off like this just know
that control there's no sense is that
there's no laces a while to come back
the [__] reality yeah you know I mean
because you're just in that place but
like is there a reason that you're like
that do you think like when you got
started or has it just always been there
do you think in you I think it's always
been nothing really
oh okay I thought I'd see no I was never
like which treated as a child or article
don't bring in all the older brother was
an [__] you know I mean it hit me off
the edge would having a [__] wank
okay I'm the [__] tosser he'd come in
with a broomstick and SWAT me mmm
probably out to bigger dick than that
was no I just think it was I always
stuck out all those I had to both people
through like it when I was 16 I was like
two six four two sixteen 16 hours old
you're black and blue one side like a
trainer piston really you know a size 38
fathers looking like you know extra
extra-large pensions so it was like I go
out to the clubs and and bounces that
kicked me out not being on the date
either but we'll just get into it with
them and you don't you just I didn't
light bounces to be honest I just didn't
like him it was just so awful about him
the lassitude
the way they'd like to get you like
chicken wing gift so that you know I
just throw you down the [__] stairs
yeah I got stairs with up with you you
bastard finally live
and then so I'll get to oblivion like
this you know what motivation is that
though what what do you think it is that
like motivates you to be that way
because you you get almost zero benefit
from doing that non-absorbable that I
mean I didn't really put much thought
into it right I've been in it I mean it
wasn't even enjoyment other than getting
joy when heard anything out of it it was
just
spas was craving for attention somehow
you know I think it was sick of [__]
sick of just been not like people being
normal who might just sick of I wants it
to be a little bit different yeah that's
what struck me a little bit about that
yeah that story is it seems like you yes
that's where you connected well yeah
yeah you both want me to get the [__]
out of witness yeah it was very sensible
plan yeah did you be a dad I call me
that yeah he did like was he a fire that
you are no no no no he's a big knock a
lot even we meet at because he getting
from work and my mom up you i he's being
[__] [__] it there is not so it could
I get a bell round the [__] that you
know I ring I did really resents in
philosophy almost every other how to
kick my ass so yes did a like just would
be at the shape sort of finger yeah
wrote well in the end is just enough
that they would arguing that more to to
come Titan Exeter diverse I left at 16
and then by the sound was 17 I was
through the bird and she was pregnant I
was living in the house working that
place called Kadesh bees the Golden
Wonder call it the crisp because it's
just literally bacon crisps right on the
woman the crisps I remember those
they're not around anymore no them
around normal
knew that if you saw another kid getting
all the Wonder out their lunch box
you're like a [__] jobless you get
paid makes you [__] quit which
southfork all small village I don't know
but it's a South Africa but every payday
you get like a big box of 48 Chris you
got your wage yeah Iceland every Sunday
Oh get like big [__] you you have you're
pregnant yeah yeah go girl you some
quite immature within that story that
you're telling like not ready for my
situation so how did that [__] feel
like it settled me down for a bit but it
went me wrong real quick because then I
felt I was missing out on things then
you know I'm saying that all with this
woman and she's pregnant
and Gavin got money to go anywhere I
haven't even got money to go in pop
another fight get it as a fight or get
into trouble I'll do anything and just
get nagged out and just like paint they
speculate this through that when you get
a job oh [__] sake well if you have any
kid or something yeah yeah yeah it just
didn't work out people like you that
this isn't lot nor disrespect me but
like I feel like they're not made for
[__] structure especially not at that
age now watch me on a [__]
battlefield in a killed swinging an axe
you feel like you were born in the wrong
age when these tell me these stories you
think right now so were you in is life
around this time oh yeah
when this should happen so I'm like
trying to like get my studies done my
degree done and stuff like that around
this time we're a partner so on the
weekends I'm doing my Raven with wild
ma'am getting dad's my studying on the
weekdays and I've seen how volatile he
is and what's going on in this country
with him so what I'm thinking you know
I'm gonna go to America get rich in the
stock market fly weilman out and get him
a job as a wrestler so we can channel
this aggressive energy this that
landscape that was the master plan that
was the structure I was gonna put on him
but as you mentioned about structure and
wild man it doesn't quite work so what
happened next sort of thing like well so
I'm out there and it's not me from going
up there
tell me about five years within five
years of start making out making the
hundreds of thousands and then while
mine came out while I was still a
stockbroker
I certainly one circuit that nine he
didn't show up at the airport yeah and
then the next the next one he came and
why did you not call the airport it's
too volatile [__] and why was he on
the first place which I just don't worry
I just don't soon a few years in prison
and I paid l5 15 months and I mean it's
ooh laughter now here's a place novel is
absolutely [__] nothing you do Lee do
half anyways 15 mph
right it was like five month in Wong
okay 15 months is quite a long time but
this is Wellman saying prison is nothing
right okay well now
so we just understand where we've gone
yet so at one point you're living with
the girl she's pregnant
yeah how did you go from that into
prison what happened does she kicks me
out did you have the kid before her she
had this kid there and kicked me out and
I see the I went back home and the kid
I'd see my daughter Ashley I don't come
up every weekend and see me I don't see
to see the dogs and that suited me oh it
sounds really an [__] saying that but
that that's all it was quite ready for
really the funny thing is normally I
think [__] but because of the
background story I think no I think so
one thing I've learned from my dad
especially is that just like because
Maya was a [__] wild man as well the
amount he was in prison Milo just some
blocks they're not ready for that when
it happens to them and then they're like
yeah exactly you know I mean like
they've still got a lot of [__] that
they want to carry on doing yeah you
don't get out the sister before they
settle down I think you knew that and
she knew that getting into that
relationship yeah yeah well it wasn't a
plan baby no [__] yeah and Lucy one of
the more of the world type of things
right and so so how did you end up
getting locked up sorry yeah oh I ended
up I heard there was a raving witness
like people just sort of go then yeah
there was like flyers on your cars when
you're coming out of previous one with
right yeah it's the hotlines you meet at
a location it will be announced on that
night it normally like be a service like
Birdwood services Flay they're seen as a
rave on such-and-such because they're
not incredibly romantic places are they
service stations no no yeah
but it is it like this is a different
time in Britain or for gaming pay phones
to find out your location because Fox
fact to you you have a fax it yeah yeah
yeah yeah was the facts knowledge page
you get on you page so you to a turning
up service stations dressed how it was
like multicolored is it similar to if
you go to that cyberdog sort of thing in
Camden now acid house as big as you all
right obey that courts of attention
because everyone just smiling and
dancing on the smoke clouds yeah yeah
it's easy to spot the other people who
are going to the rave when you get to
the service station whole service
station at 2:00 in the morning it's just
the whole car park completely full right
ravers right
please come deal with it no I'll see you
you're on the way of the rim though
right right so oh so I hope there's a
rave on Weiland down there someone goes
there's a physically local sound now
there wasn't really many raves though
and he said there's a guy he got two
thousand these on him he's coming up the
South follow yeah loving it [__] you
didn't get me [__] gyro spent me
guide or countdown the Sangha emergency
tried all didn't [__] work really say
you've lost it so many [__] Sam's can
you know the rain so I go down there and
waiting for him and then they walk up
it's you sounds got any ease I don't
know what you're on about along with a
couple Watson's about three or four I
said you want some ease oh yeah yeah so
the second round the car I befriended
and banking and work sounds [__] it's
the wrong [__] guy
it's the wrong people
you are innocent and that guy had no no
no agency [__] Pope we would man it's
[__] brilliant I'm gonna get amazed
give me a bag yeah if you have enough
money for a kebab blow and then was i
eating some change to pound eighty
fellow yeah right literally the next day
if the police comes to me [__] out
our police through us as well and the
coke it could be [__] dard is a lot
and got them for street robbery hosting
little street robbery party which said
that you robbed him and thinking [__]
lay investment so a lot of folks that's
all [__] they come back you bad what
do you can't you know I made Jolie yeah
cut a long story short I got soon a few
sweet pound baby Jesus Christ that's
like a month for every foot big temp and
I know
so Jesus wake you guys present I was in
Walton for five months right I got
sentenced in Warrington I went to Walton
five month I known from Walton I went
sir Northumberland a Quincy and then
five Don's there and then I finished off
at a place called a home house stops and
on sees how bad do you think you heard
this guy just roughly was he just chind
was it was he really hurt I know I
might've am not to choose that was a bit
of a swollen jaw do you have you [__]
know it was really one take
yes so there'd be people watching this
now who are like [__] another him just
for so it like do you know what I'm
saying yeah so I'm trying to think from
their point of view like did you feel
guilty when you afterwards when you are
on the way at present did you feel like
I shouldn't have done that or is your
state of mind just like I felt like he
could please [__] [__] to do it in
this place to be honest with you you
know I really thought it was just spur
is amor is just following things I
didn't have anything better out there
you got it when you didn't have these
that's a genuine question I was really
not father's got a kebab are right
mm and you know I'm not endorsing drug
use day you know X is terrible but you
know kebab some people assault and I'll
probably give him away anyway it wasn't
about the money
they'll probably would have sold so yeah
the like everyone's friend of that right
but yeah just throw them yeah yeah it
was am thinking about it should have
done it book you say that I bought a lot
of things in hindsight God you know
really we start a podcast well I love
this I'm convinced now is just gonna
spend the rest of his life in prison if
that's what he's doing is just gonna get
out through something else I don't think
he's only chance now is if we get him
out into America for already in America
while he's impressed I'm building must
stop by my wireless easing prisoner on
the comma and sure only solution is that
he wrestles in America wrestling that's
the way out of it like a part of a house
near the george & dragon british pub in
phoenix arizona I figured the British
hang out with again was idealistic yeah
yeah so you arrived in is it sleepy
quite sleepy town or what ceramics
Arizona like no the area he's in was it
central Phoenix and rightfully so a nice
it it was it was bustling but that baby
was just after I was in way it was a
Mexican neighborhood it's it's ha was on
a culture shock sorry oh yes cuz I mean
even a London
I've just I just met him at the gate
they're like [__] about London no Mexico
is even more [__] yeah are in the
main Mexican area Mexico Arizona site is
is much more different again I'm driving
him back from the airport
he's like pull over pull over why what's
up LA I want to see that cuts as well
have a look at that trans right maybe
she's swaro CATSA be like you know 20
foot high roughly we talking here this
is middle nineties isn't it now do you
know what I mean yeah like this is like
you know the movies that people are
making now they're making movies about
that era yeah I mean your story is very
similar wolf of Wall Street I'm not
exactly a classic yeah yeah but like
even though you ride with people for
kebabs yeah
describing this whole I mean we've heard
two parts of your story
oh yeah it is very like something like
Grand Theft Auto I mean so you're on
your way this is a whole new place for
you a new start
what's your mind stare right now we're
in in this place I'm just happy yeah I'm
just happy to see Shawn best mate you
know already and so I'll just get out
with their scout what prison get out
I mean but then it was only about 18
I'll say only I was about 18 18 a star
so I was thinner a lot they look at
first of all um no you must have been
[__] huge to that watch
you must have been a unit over here
looking at your [__] shoulders when
you walk we have bigger bounty cells
yeah but um yeah I enjoyed it it was
like couldn't wait to get there and you
seen different things and it's cactus or
getting off playing sort of [__] else
just like they you imagine like [__]
you've been in the microwave rousu -
playing door opens [__] the hotter
Wow almost 50 degrees dry here yeah
you'll have never come into contact with
America is very different air isn't it
well that'd be the broad since then I've
never been anywhere I mean most people
go this is your first first sound Rover
I'll never go like Greece or Spain or
you know sir power to go for the week
but it's very first time ever America
Sean didn't want to lower you in general
[Music]
are you aware that Sean's on the cross
in the way we come in a millionaire he I
know that's all I know that he's doing
all right for himself but I'm just glad
that he's got one of you tickets man
pick a bit more it's like how little you
idolized every city like you lived life
you know you didn't think about you just
when it did it yeah yeah yeah I like
that but so you're trying to look out
from at this point yeah and after a few
weeks mean the woman was if it Sam would
go over to visit him at his place that
have rented for him knock on the door
and like Peter Peter thought autumn
slowly and as all these Mexican
gangsters in there we're gonna put me
enough for you and my worst piece of was
pizza like Pisa was on honey pizza for
you to me pizza pizza on pizza he lives
I rented this place what's going on last
night yelling Peter Peter so then they
like come at me at the door pull the
guns out the burden wave she's like oh
[__] and we start like backpedaling away
from them freaky were about to get shot
and he walks over the road he's like oh
don't worry LA these are my new mates
they're our meth and crack dealers
there's a Colombian one who runs the
gang I've rented my place out to them
because he likes to move around the law
clever
we were like me of a burger like we just
really got shot sold us yeah like a few
quid out of it yeah a big one for the
craic
they have to just move to replace 50
yards down the road so they said I could
stay there the police are just a wreck
busted the place right but they're still
rinsing it out
so I can stay there make sure that [__]
you and if any come knocking on the door
say oh do you shop area that we were
pausing at how big a crack rocky could
there in one breath a crack rock fence
I'll bring you what I do help me can you
get a crack get this to get a kilo size
it just depends on you magnet but I was
literally let me most people a small
crop mother you got addicted very very
cool yeah well you were you like
addicted at that point
nobly the first time I've ever done it
and I did a massive rock and it was just
like it felt good to felt really good
fight it was just best I've ever had
it's like instance a you Matt you wait
you have a dumb TV your power wherever
and LSD was our I mean I like to kick
you know you mind a little bit but and
we'd yeah but that we it's just like you
know what was the difference between
crack and the others because the other
seem to be quite straightforward what
does crack give you an instant instant
you fairy I used and I got in every
single hair on your back every hair on
your head just stands up and you know
you almost just [__] coming your
pants third and then you know me right
it's just an absolutely lovely feeling
yeah meets right I can't stand it really
lasts a couple of minutes you like and
it's gone and when I could say in and be
happy for five hours
alright so it wasn't a long less than
high you know you first how you'd only
how you first hit Jimmy high and then
people just chase it I knew that and I
wasn't like that I just have one big
fuck-off what's that rock and just leave
it to the next day though because that
seems quite um like someone who's quite
in control
yeah that's going on will you sort of
were you you would always say to me
don't let the juice control you we
control the drug right that was he
saying by the mentality really anything
it drugs
well loosed at so many of the drugs to
do to right
a crystal meth to try out never done
that before
how what was the experience with that it
was nice to just like use all different
experience just meth for me is the truck
that when you watch TV it's the ones
where it's the model picture like a
supermodel of ticketing it's a
before-and-after yeah yeah she is
looking gorgeous and here she is looking
[__] run sitting after the drugs
recta like but in my head I'm like at
some point when the girl sees our self
[__] deteriorate and she'll she'll
stop did they can't why is that why
can't I stop think you don't see it they
don't see as they've got a problem
before the end it's too late whilst he
sees a problem devoted he got the
[__] sores on the face and they
always were already looking [__]
[__] up anyways like I got chocolate
meth Mexicans yeah they're made of
themselves don't ya you don't sleep you
don't sleep for days and things by those
that's the other thing as well like with
crack you got to keep buying it with
meth people moved from coal because
caught you got to keep buying but math
you do one line you're out you're high
for a day really oh yeah you don't need
to sleep anything you superhuman did the
price reflect that I was nothing more
expensive oh is it all this is she dead
sheep wasn't it in Arizona cuz we're
right next to Mexico right so I'm really
about this but I've never paid for
George wants is America really sure it's
like 7-eleven for you downstairs
basically yeah they said if Sean wasn't
around I've made me on I don't have to
go a lot people everywhere they're like
oh you'd have been a millionaire maybe
Sean was holding you back yeah deal he
would just eat any amount of drugs I
gave him he would consumer himself
it's like Brian being a McDonald's
dealer don't get high on your own supply
we were driving to a rave one time in
this car and we were paranoid about
police being behind us a lot in the car
so in the car like an actress
not an ounce of meth so far right
someone's gonna eat the ounce of meth
[__] and then we get to this rave big
burly inside yeah it was cold up there
and you were like just sweating will I
actually felt sad I'm surprised you
didn't know he was he was join that
first trip thank you
which you in bed go um it's a hospital
multiple times yeah high on crack and
math and he just go walkabout and I
wouldn't know where he was four days
it's show up days later with holes in
his shoes you couldn't even tell me
where I've been all right done I think
if you stop doing that stop broke
douchiest have kept the better Iommi
things like why are you would you were
you sexually active at that time as well
oh you sure must [__] a lot of very
attractive women from the stories he
tells us just to be clear was that true
yeah it was right through so we stopped
joining in on this and Donovan was
underage right yeah good
were you so joining in on that will you
you know I don't mean on the same people
but you know we you well man met a woman
that was into getting tased oh yeah we
remember that from right episode two if
you don't showed up at the house party
we were throwing with a boyfriend some
bouncer dude
Oh Cory and you've already got services
yeah yes a real man now some people call
us out using different names different
stories we have to change names for
legal reasons right maybe the same
different names for the same story right
just for the YouTube yeah yeah it's
[__] Western you give it'd be like
five days ago we should listen read it
and make sure you know all the things so
we'll be out but make sure the legal
names are illegal names I [__] up
precious longer than the original
edition this one right here well man is
throughout that bought all of his most
crazy stories Wow
so just just stays the Taser girl like
just to be clear she likes stun guns on
her [__] she just shows up at this house
party with a boyfriend
bouncer yeah she sends a boyfriend after
make some spaghetti bolognese meal
that's unusual thing to turn up to
partying doing isn't it well I actually
saw the Sudokus orchid and she was like
I should you shot there she's flushing a
Minji anyway
gosh it's something yeah that's look you
know so you try wait here we go girl of
that sousaphone softly she worked a nude
strip club yeah right so she was
attractive yes yeah so skinny or give me
black half white what to call mulatos
mixed mixed race
sorry MXC so she's flashing your vagina
and you're just thinking how do we get
rid of him I know spaghetti bolognaise
well the best food talk is I thought
just get him out of the room and she
said she was gonna like taser well I
first got the Taser call-out and Iife
dad says out of yourself a little bit
that was his party trick
it just bought the turns around just
thought saved himself and people are
gathering around sort of going
that's impressive yeah yeah did you just
do me harm like he was getting tickled
anything hurt
oh yeah bird you see them uh you don't
like it you know I wouldn't just do this
I believe it's - I think I'm minutes
thirty seconds was the longest I've
known for actually Scott so balls so
she's going on shows out there with
[__] [__] but we've gotta get rid of
him I said I'll give him summation skate
bolognaise because that does in the
kitchen they have the ingredients forget
bolognese sauce
yes so she basically sent him in there
and then she did the show and like
[__] she gets a [__] out and I got
to say is that all she got so what I'm
thinking right now I wonder where she is
right on my facebook which is pop back
on unbelievable yeah I mean all right no
I'm thinking to myself though like
imagine being that girl and now we're
all having a [__] story like she's
legendary
she solidified you know it's like a
tattoo model something now she's totally
down still she was even boss to talk to
you guys like I guarantee Ryan's idea
so I'm trying to build a picture of your
character at that time yeah we sort of
girlfriend to girlfriend it was it so
just like Bonnie and Clyde with this one
Rakeem it was wild woman was back in
England well woman it seems a lot like
you were not semester there was a
[__] around right I was wrong didn't
need super girls dude
so on the timeline sorry in a timeline
so right now in my head it's like you've
come Arizona you have made friends with
the the Mafia so a while warm he's gone
to get a bottle of milk and jumped on
the plane resulting we forgot look you
told your girlfriend yeah I'm going for
a bottle of milk and you got on a plane
and with Arizona I'm not the one you got
pregnant no I said it was gonna get you
a newspaper so sorry right and then from
America because Tommy yeah and probably
to the airport and then we only got
deported and went back this I actually
went around with the newspaper and she
took me back in so so you so you'd be in
mixing with drugs for a while why did he
get deported was that was just your type
isn't a violation of things let's go
everything just escalated fine
yeah well I lied to leave I landed up in
this apartment in the first places where
he put me in this Mexican area there's a
well basically a guy come around having
a bit of a party with evidence of smoke
and some crackers stuff gathering please
gather you it's making friends whose
girlfriend this girlfriend goes off the
rolls go after Mexicans so I'm talking
to this guy and he's got a gun and like
it all this is all news to me hasn't he
been in Medicare I'm gonna be
once wasn't it there's about three
months already
okay no no no say I you did say good
morning to me in Spanish around there
anyway nice the neighbors like me so
Carlos Tony sure this guide shows me
he's got it all up give it him back I
mean he said this is how we do in
America put the gun through that and
shots herself on me dog dead dad dirt my
I got a call at the brokerage from Milan
saying you need to get out to Peters
apartment right now it's headline news
and there's police tape all over his
street you might have killed himself or
he might be dead so why did that person
comes I have no clue I have no clue to
this day he thought the safety was on
yeah or yeah like so [__] Russian
Roulette sale [__] like just spinning
barrel he was on drugs and yeah right
yeah he was just literally he was too
just thought the thing and it was just
enough thank common here's how we do in
America but the gun Suzette and I was
just expenses way like click delivery
you could has allowed them yeah he's a
weird [__] ringing what was your
reaction well after both worried about
me you didn't see enough that's not the
alphadon the our hope was [__] house
first few actually was off [__] you know
what the neighbors gonna serve all this
yeah yeah dad [__] he got a big over
there he's I'm [__] outside the
[__] door was that the first time you
seen a dead body
yeah its first I would say I don't bully
so how how did that impact you because
for a lot of people that's all Fox you
have you really want staying that
enabled for stayed there for a couple of
weeks afterwards but I just kind of said
use every night weird you know every but
you will be haunted by you [__] would
make like ya know it really got got to
be a little bit like I don't think you
were [__] else I've got a sleeper
know outside see it repeating me I'd
repeated me yet
and then I stopped doing drugs for a bit
there as I've started to in conditional
[__] I was of the Corolla [__] 40
ounces [__] King Cole all right yeah
malt liquor yeah and I was just thinking
them for a bit
and then [__] he wasn't getting along
with his roommates Eva no the Mexicans
no no he had some roommates all right I
showed up some dirty schmuck it's right
I showed up and Wildman's in both side
of the house bare wriggling around on
the floor and he's dropping the TV on
one picking it off and then dropping the
TV on the other size my fault
did it provoke him they did provoke him
yeah uh-huh
you drop a TV on his own I'm not going
this podcast has had some mad [__] right
we've said we've had some like my people
yeah guy shot his [__] on face off
he's [__] up about it and then he goes
and he wasn't getting on with his
roommates that was a mental person what
happens stuff ten times more men saw but
they didn't mean Robby lifted beetles
and [__] round to my own warmed or not
to leave needles on his side in the
bathroom and stuff and he left me he
goes yeah constructed something that I
wrote you know don't ask when we [__]
your name you've got the wriggled his
hairdo just went to get on his head oh
my god after the ankle as well so you
think recover from that yeah oh yeah as
well stop there big killing doing dad
okay so you end up going home after
after this all gets too much no
residents just beginning he looks at
some Mexican Mafia guys and all lists of
his stuff and he's got rushing after you
come over his next play there's a place
before that wasn't the Gangster
Disciples plays yeah he said for the
wall well I couldn't leave a cost you
anyway at that point because the police
homicide guy in them too did so bit dad
and they took the passport off me right
because they wanted you not to go
anywhere because you suspect yeah right
so I was there first
actually it was at the apartment four
baths that say about the iPhone within
six weeks me being there so yeah
probably they have about twelve weeks
and then well the homicide people come
and I fell off sounds getting fastball
but and we did the compass it classed as
what was it anything exit ask use an
accident yeah and they did you have
drugs in the house they didn't come
investigate the house it because there's
a woman as he consumes all these drugs
immediately right so the police
convinced his house there in his body
right okay yeah I mean there's a there's
a Netflix series on right now called the
staircase where the girls found at the
bottom of the staircase and their
husband did he do it did he not do yes I
love you I don't there's a guy with a
hole in his [__] head and I'm a
smoking gun there yeah I mean
realistically looking at you in the
behavior that you to a prior that you
did well not to get [__] the blame I
feel very well powder test shows you
shotgun Wow yah yah yah yah did
something down there and all let me go
possible they must I thought you
definitely did it before they did the
terror was known right away yeah yeah
right and so after that where do you
then go Gangster Disciples
apartment on the west side oh yeah
this is all a joke what does this mean
it genuinely sounds like an area in
trouble out of trouble yeah so hey what
the card says the site yeah I got
Burnside for this place for a while
ma'am this is a new place yeah say my
cousin's over you know he's visiting
from England the motel the rental place
you know he's a good lad we want to just
keep him in there for a bit blah blah
blah yeah this is just the first visit
he comes back in the late nineties when
I've got the big money I'm coming up
making hundreds of thousand apartments
you're okay cool right well I do that
yeah boy you'll see what that happens to
them right oh yeah I mean I'm putting in
a safe distance from my house right now
yeah so these two women and this guy is
the disciple 30 thinks he's so feasible
sir he's got his cowboy hat see the
problem they haven't even cashed my
check at the rental place and I get a
call saying Peters being evicted because
he's put his roommates head through the
plasterboard wall he tries to sell me
house Jesus rules these are the house
rules by the way I said one I said did
you see him put in this guy's head
through the plasterboard wall no we
didn't see him putting his head through
the plasterboard wall but numerous of
the neighbors saw the guy running scared
for his life through the complex with
powder
any trick no I think he was itself
guided me yeah yeah he [__] up it did
he pay the wrong one
pick the wrong guy yeah give it that
little bit of me oh you just you picked
the wrong guy looks at you and thinks
stuff I tell you what there was a guy
pulled in I was as I was waiting for
tuck see the day pulled in right in
front of his any sort of he went to sort
of give her finger working in the
passenger seat and I just look them dead
like I was dead inside like look I think
I want you to do it and then he just saw
and he just like put this you came so
close that I like the story when you
were doing the dive in and you don't go
into the bar and he starts singing the
songs in the Scottish oh you got $1
issued its you also really got this guy
that was my story on the one where two
two guys start on wanna be me at the
Bulbul cues and I did a puttin one of
them to sleep basically I don't got a
wild story when Robin said to you I like
that
so selfies clicking in my head now the
woman and where she knew people who are
addicted to crack and she's like you got
get while man away from central Phoenix
now people what we [__] there Tempe
was like the party town a University of
Arizona
it wasn't like a crack meth confessed in
a body is more like the club drug scene
party so many young college girls right
twenties right you were eating when you
first right now you're at this new place
how many years later you in the 20s now
I'm mid twenties mid select getting just
punch must meet where's your to food 96
you took me there it's gotta be in 2296
I was born in 72 hours whatever that is
right so you twenty five ish yeah yeah
see your stuff very much in your prime
your twenties mmm college girls college
girls big tough guy you know from
England you're a little bit exotic so
you moved into Tempe in this apartment
that's where you met yeah yeah yeah sure
we started our first ecstasy parties I
was giving it away in the beginning and
it propels our going so fast it's where
I saw the business potential of it and
the ecstasy Empire because began in his
apartment
Rancho Maria own temps in case anyone
isn't also given the way I was picking
money for the guys so you seen the
business potential and just a refresh
people's memories how did you go from
all right so on one hand your stuff
broke out of this pipe making yeah good
money
yeah how do you go from others a
business opportunity here to making the
kind of money you did and what kinda
money was it again just for people
alright so at this point of the story
well man I'm so much fun with Wellman
these apartments versus all this rat
race stuff for her I think you know I
could make a lifestyle up with this do
what you love do what I love and we went
out to LA just started buying you know
into thousands a timeloss thousands at a
time you came out a few times and we
drive out to LA and stuff and you be in
the car I'm just working out now and
actually she kicked me out at that stage
I'm going back to when you're in England
region when it was 21 I'm a 21st
birthday I got my sentence yeah didn't
want to call how low to mid-twenties
yeah this part of story yes yeah yeah it
also blends in doesn't make it horror in
yeah especially with that kind of drug
so where did the money come on this
point warmers is gonna accelerate into
insanity and get deported and I'm then
gonna keep building this ectasy
organization while he's back in the UK
right
and he's not gonna come back now on so
about free years later so what a rich
point now it's like a multi-million
dollar so what vision was just to give a
condensed refresher for ya who may not
have seen episode 2 what happens in that
well mom so many toys for me like I said
he meets these people he tracks these
people they were all the key people that
I then hired to work in the organization
so this is the New Mexico mafiosos well
they were protecting us fruit g-dogg
yeah
generally it was like the local rave
scene right so all these little rave
cliques are competing against each other
and they come into a wild man because
they've got beefs and they want wow man
to sort things out for them
but in the end what we did was we you
know if the Malta Gavin had them all
working together under our control
didn't really love we got into the
college so college scene but basically
with front them pills from them pills
from itself as a point where you know
eventually the one who's gonna [__] up
and not all you know me yeah
well it's like alright well you just go
so Amsterdam pick you some pills of the
car but that quits so yeah and so your
until the frat houses and things like
that yeah I know well they would come to
Rancho Murieta
and then by world appears yeah it's
weirdly you were bit like me a new
Lawrence yeah different but work really
well because you're sort of you know the
mastermind behind getting the money and
all of that innovation and you are quite
a feared guy in this in this respect so
you know you're the one telling them all
right we'll call the day off if you do
the [__] I'm Saddam tree yes the best
way to get people to pay me money was
not tough wild man beat them up it was a
wild man moving with them right I use
that method I use that method for years
because like I said Susie moves in all
these guys are coming over they leave
within weeks everyone was terrified a
while my moving in with them right you
you are a really good jewel a
you know I'm saying those so yeah you
work well together
what's he getting back in the country
that was not easy so how much money are
you making and roughly monthly would you
say by the time while because you
continue the operation while white man's
being back in England
yeah how much money would you say
monthly you'll make and because there's
some big numbers all right so it's
building up its not set amount it's just
getting bigger and bigger each year tour
the peak here peak year was probably
about 99 were by I've got people coming
back with up to 30 40 thousand hits at a
time 34,000 hits I said so ecstasy pills
well so what is their worst we're back
to three quid in hot in Holland I pay
two or three dollars and they'd go fast
well they go for 20 to 30 in America so
I front them out of their heads of my
divisions at $10 so I'll say I'll give a
head of one division five thousand pills
at ten yeah I've tried it yeah when he
sells into his middle man who said in
sales a month of the stream so I don't
have to interact with any of that
I'm just sat back close like been the
money six or thirty forty thousand pills
shrunken strands treatment was that like
a six hundred crime basically yeah if
I'm paint if I'm front about ten and
paying to a free on thirty forty
thousand my actual profit will be about
a quarter of a million and and what the
street value that they eventually go for
just what value twenty six seven hundred
thousand yeah yeah startup and that's
monthly that's kobe monthly forever in
ROM but sometimes there were
unpredictable things that would arise in
that business yeah so again so you come
back and so you left where it was a much
smaller operation by the time you come
back you're really [__] good well you
do better the apartments got nicer than
us yes it'll be nicer area yeah yeah so
what in England have you covered that
yeah oh so you go about there he goes
back to wild woman now he's got some
explaining to do you gonna use
I've got a huge paper see [__] he kicks
read the balls let's the kicks beating
the balls what was that
Oh [__] celebrates come in hell we
got who met Mabel time ing let me back
in she said don't ever leave me again
are you still with her no no no she
didn't listen then I'm with another
improved yeah she says to you never
leave me and you go absolutely not yeah
how soon do you leave after that oh she
comes I bring her with us she ended up
number two in the crime so every time
you say there was a newspaper after that
she's gone sink so what happens in
England over those three years it's okay
to the tide and everything's going okay
and I also have a little flattened in
witless sound sensitive then like that's
basically just word I've gone small
Weems stuff like that you know if he
ever did go out go home it's because she
knows more about we bring people back in
like stayed up till all hours and shed
free kids swell souls fair I thought
this past place where we just go I
wouldn't cheat all I want to do for Carl
I wouldn't say it no [__] back our
holes but but I just yeah how I can get
drunken [__] but one of the roommates
there once again roommates well haven't
I said as we passed it one of them tries
it me little brother cut a long story
short I throw him down the stairs and
stump on his head a few times and a [__]
him up and he ends up [__] going off
spell and he can't speak for like two or
three months or something like that and
he doing for like his sexual section 18
and somewhat intent to yeah and I'm
looking at [__] seriously it's I am
again out me so while I'm waiting for
the charges I'm thinking hmm I'm saying
gee fancy coming [__] America and
she's like no one of all the kids I said
we'll let the dad out the kids for the
wild he's always [__] my eyes and
wants us to see you anyway
and then [__] eventually we resets up
out there we will bring them over not a
problem
Oh out there any few fears don't leave
me okay then
and that's that's how we end up going
back over but I couldn't travel with
them they could that they traveled
straight into America I had to go via a
different country which country Mexico
well the first one which Mexico was
understand like Mission Impossible style
teams of people through multiple
countries of duties various deportations
for being a miniature society and but
how do you have money on your back in
England she's gonna get another job in
the chrisbattery oh no dull dull and
she'd she'd be on the sick she'd got any
money and [__] babies fathers pails
equivalent right
so those baby but my doll would be
basically me on so happy be money so he
flat which free as well
why because it was on the doll you got
free fun council houses yeah I council
house okay right sorry you had it for
other sort of nefarious challenges you
know what I mean that he's gotta bathe
right so um you then go back to America
and by this point your richest [__] yeah
our situation as well alright cuz the
first time you come the second time you
come was the Schooley situation yes it
was right so I've got this multi-million
dollar thing now going my drug debt to
probably got half a million right now of
all people who work for
all right and man it was with top
ecstasy salesperson he's the one who
sent me the balls crew knock these teeth
out and stuff like that and he got he
got into smoking embalming fluid he was
smoking crack smoking crystal meth and
he started to plot against me and he
started to poison some of my other
bouncers mines against me and seems to
me shortly covered a mate like him like
the ideal for this situation I think
that's like me to waifu' kids so I pick
him up from the Greyhound bus station
he's been smuggled and first stop is
this guy's house do you tell him at this
point what's been going on the way to
the house this couldn't need sword well
I say I want you to assess the situation
because here's what happened that's the
situation internal strife right now this
guy will call him Skinner easy on LSD
chemist he was manufacturing LSD who had
an apartment just for it thousands of
thousands of hits laid out gel tabs so
well as the chemist got all this there's
this stuff in his house as well and
Skinner tells me LSD chemist guy we're
gonna come over they wanna buy you know
so many tens of thousands of hits of LSD
but he brings over these Southside
gangsters with guns but my LSD chemist
was suspicious from the get-go so he had
guys with a K right ATK's and everything
in the back of the house they come over
to but to pretend to buy the asset they
were gonna rub together did he remember
dude but yeah he pulls out a shotgun
start shooting the guys of the a case
that unload then bullets start going
through all the neighbors houses and
this is headline news
so LSD guy is blaming Skinner skin is
blaming LSD guy and this is one of the
main problems there because this is just
happened when Wellman got there as well
so we're like we're going to
just gonna go in and calmly ask Skinner
for his side of the story and that's
what we did
so what happened next I wants to Cyprian
him I really did like wise up me did you
not trust up from the or not they want
first time same day or just the story
you just sell it was just [__] it was
off is that will you be no fair enough
Sarge you know when he had off you
[__] that you know Leroy and his
stories him the way he was going on and
on and on
I thought socialist bastards you started
and I said we haven't I would throw him
over the balcony old second the Desert
Inn Alfred
and he said doctors make me the most
money I said look at the end of the day
I said he might be making the most e
money but you got your lashes guy if you
got to [__] people in the firm
[__] making lots of money in that at
war the other one loses [__] out
yeah there was bought as well because
yeah girlfriend Marie this Iranian
American lady who was really tough and
she was really supportive of everything
I was doing and they had a baby together
is gonna so Skinner
we should have thought about I showed me
how solid that's you any sensible [__]
aside that ultimately skin is what he
did later on the whole organization then
Wellman was right but I fought if we
escalated things through that level of
violence against people working for me
the police would get involved and they
were just think so you try to play
things cool calm and the negotiator the
diplomat no you that's why you to like
me Lawrence that's why you to work well
together yeah and you're the sensible
you're a diplomat he's like to the
desert I'm like so you talked him over
that and that yeah my happened at the
table what happened next day well he put
the fear of God in him because as soon
as Skinner answers the die sees me he's
like big brother and he's hugging me and
everything smiling as soon as he sees
him is facial and you know how he was up
at the stories we heard the stories
if yes sir mr. super five minutes
brain-eater thought about this story
weilman's presence did put him in check
for a little bit yeah boy it didn't last
because I cut
as a condo so your presence and memoir
so Wellman's back in america now its
first night in tempe we have a little
welcoming back for wild man and party
LSP guy shows up to give well many side
of the story we believe his side of
story
so a few people show everything's going
quite cool mellow people are enjoying
themselves and then this guy showed up
who just said a few wrong things that
Wellman took objection seven ended up
getting thrown down the stairs and the
next thing while man threw him down the
stairs yeah the next thing the police
are on the way but I don't know this
there's a nice complaint front office
has been told they contact me about a
nice plate I say I'm gonna keep it down
send everybody home now the only two
people left in the hotel room now a wild
man and another one of my balance is
called Robbie Righetti I used to sell
rubble you get these stories about wild
man before he came all about well Robbie
got he said he's bigger in life than I
possibly imagined he picked me up and
threw me around like I was a teddy bear
right I lived with Robbie for awhile so
these guys are right yeah okay yeah he
was Italian gleep okay yeah because
could be this club which is obviously
what you are against he's making you
forget
and you to a good II took a French I
think there's no noise now to sell down
problems over next thing knock at the
door right I look through the door
people around the apartment guy were a
hotel guy with a policeman so I think
whaleman's bites his first day I've
spent tens over ten thousand smuggling
them back in and now here's what's gonna
happen
he's going to get arrested and deported
right away so the hotel guy says can we
come in
I said no everybody's gone home it's
gone quiet you know New Mexican Mafia
tell me what to say to the police and
people like this and the policeman
turned to the hotel man and said do you
give me permission to come in to look
for property damage and the whole salad
man goes yes I give you permission this
is bad for me
[__] so well man and Ragetti are on the
bed letting your pertains be sleeper
cell for the air on these beds and the
police and then the hotel man is God
like rustling through the trash ashtrays
looking for evidence of weed or
something so they can call all the cops
I never saw arrested but there was no
evidence of anything like that and you
pop your head up you bloodshot big blue
eyes
I kind of lagged him a bit and then
they'd be left suspiciously quickly and
then what started happened was I was
scoping out the area and police cars
were gathering up the road and they were
gonna do a full-on swoop and just arrest
all of us because this little cop
probably couldn't have done much against
him he had all these backup guys up the
road well they could have had a [__]
gun
oh yeah yeah but you could have just
knocked them out of season he probably
felt threatened so I'm like alright
we're just getting the [__] out of here
right now
we left so quickly through this route
like we've got cats I got cactus spine
stuck in my leg and everything
[Music]
going to SUV in the night sucking some I
we dodged the cops I took you to a
million dollar house on the side of the
mountain the gate guarded community yeah
when's bed with my wife woke up the next
day wild man is like on the porch like
asleep like a grizzly bird with his face
up like this in the heating in the Sun
of the desert completely covered in
cactus spines the owner I lived the real
estate person said don't go outside of
the house permit because the
rattlesnakes and the cactuses and the
dangerous insects while manna just
wandered the whole neighborhood the
knife fallen down ravines just look
completely coming we're just picking all
these cactus spines out all I've never
seen the desert at all I mean you'd open
these but you've got this place where
pearl he's got this and like they have
these big huge tarantulas [__] on the
box yeah so I went for a walk around
[__] trip dollar fellow these
campuses of [__] naked [__] statue
some secured fell asleep the between my
legs and I see fall asleep in the
[__] so was my water for his
forbearance a [__] yeah another but wife
threw that guy down the [__] stairs
you must take this case there was a lot
of people's I was thirsty
yes you got a [__] god ed put on me
look this the Alves party thing and I he
was a snipe it was like a jock
what I mean by a jockey was American
football yeah and he was just basically
like we got so I'll kill it or I might
have bumped into our he bumped into me
and someone was [__] said why you
started [__] yeah and then he was just
like [__] Charlie copy and he had
like stop small months in drama small
really stocky so he'd come up [__] all
we've got an old baby wets and hugged me
so I sawed off 30 enough as he had told
me he [__] head but being got me
right and [__] him after yeah so I'm
sorry but the whole the whole worm it's
on no yes Father is no said it was weak
as it is
ever was annexed to [__] people over it
was like a big wave that would rip me
off yeah it was like people pulling you
back people pull him back the whole room
was like this big wave that was cause
you want drugs man he's got gun and
everyone else a [__] big picture you
just Peyton's like him cut this fall
over a million pound house like yeah by
the pool it's like yeah this has to be
missing the movie is such a mental
[__] story yes no he comes over on his
off first right
she comes late so this is the why oh
yeah what a good party but yeah I said
tickets to go I kept my promise to the
Decatur over yeah yeah yeah so do you do
you ever go back to that hotel after all
that [__] don't you know know there was
some hotels we could get waivers [__]
and I knew where they were and we
focused on and they were like sort of
friendly do you
yeah I'm we have friendly limo drivers
but we had a friend a limo driver who
was unfriendly and we were all going to
rave it was got a limo didn't they out
and the ovens burn laughter you'll never
one of my workers birthdays get this
limo so we're all looking forward having
a good time calling this rave and
there's a bottle of GHB now gamma
hydroxide buta make you drink a cap full
of it and that's your high you know that
I used to be a ticket of this by the way
yeah [__] Juba dreams for camel full
of it
bodybuilders used to drink it relaxes
you put you in deep sleep promotes
muscular growth that's why we died like
that yeah so you drink at full of it
it's quite a nice high up she's my
second favorite after E so the bottles
going around from person to person in
the limo well just goes [__] off and
drinks the whole box
Jesus Christ yeah I mean because it the
whole point is if you stay awake on that
you're a wreck
your arse you should see my mom urgency
emergency workers health workers about
yeses and fire engines a nephron that
came to try and literally you know like
a cup lay a little shop yeah and you're
done for the night
yeah you drink well how many how many
cups worth I probably say it was like it
wasn't a fall a lot baking it's probably
more I'd say like I know like get them
kids juice balls yeah about a ball ball
that size
I'll Drive us snitches us out next the
cops are trying like drug cess people
and everything and then we're dodging
the lemon I wake up and I see little
tubes that rami know but the good thing
about it is it doesn't come up with
structure right I love how effect the
positive your anger come up right now
he's back in town he's he's your heavy
sort of thing yeah if you're the
Godfather he's look up ROTC basic yeah
yeah he's a Fiat [__] I've
definitely so what happens now you're on
the come you're making more money this
for me is the part where it's not just
me to know sure we use well yeah GG yeah
yeah this this is Scarface this is the
bit where the montage kicks in in it and
all the money's piling up here
you know I say like it's all hot then
yeah you having fun no other go did it
follow me right do you ever see anyone
in one of those machines because they
look we rented an apartment for it yeah
you did it all in there
why are they in sports bike [__]
you know you have so much money when you
rent an apartment just a guy who you
read said you paid super count you
[__] Rudy yeah should I be you see
you my old man apitla cuz you're quite
an extremist like in a sense of
everything you do you want to take it as
far as you possibly come yeah I don't
know why I'm like that I wish they are
because I've got that along now yeah
yeah I just come with age every time I
just seems to be married at some point
though you've experienced like all of
those extreme these can be very same in
don't it yeah you've got the nicest yeah
he's quite nice to sit down and I've got
a dog a velocipede Molly book called
Sadie it's really nice to chill with me
dog and kill me why well she goes
upstairs watch TV when she comes in from
where I fit kitchens with me dad's
through the week so I will now finish
work like kick it with me dog then just
like [__] him
say so why fight over me make it a tape
and just [__] chill what is she
thinking your stories and when did you
guys she's not really that well she's
well she's completely opposite to me
like she saw sweat in the counsel most
of her life and now she's an ombudsman
service person she works at all my
service
she's got like like chemical ever asked
degrees and I like that but you found a
female mother
alright that doesn't end well okay can I
be nice for a sec
I enjoyed its nan for being flush as
[__] at hell yeah
come downstairs breakfast come
downstairs have you see nice filet
mignons crack allowance and steak
allowance yeah are you giving them salt
pocket money to peel a crack in the
state allowance but always strip clubs
having meals and efforts getting along
nicely in Tucson but then was a few
situations went down the Ramada like
what these situations it always will be
me [__] so I'm thinking he's finished
in Tucson now let's move him to Phoenix
now like I said everybody feared wild
man moving in with them why I had this
really tough female friend Sally whack
who she said she'd called herself the
head of the Department of dykes wherever
we went raven she'd be like getting all
these women and doing the dyke triangles
and stuff like that with them so what's
a dyke you ask that on the first podcast
head-to-tail in the triangle formation
now I'm selling well man I'm moving in
with her and use a watch she knows she
knows what he's like call Robert Logan
oh yeah call her I would say look she's
like I can't have one man into sin
anymore he's got a bit harp yeah and
first thing she said was move him in
with me
I'm like Sully what I'm expecting quick
look at everybody's places that he's
moved in with do you seriously want that
happening to you she was like he won't
[__] with me like that I love him
walking my dogs and
I've got a problem with some people
right now get him down here
alright so you you can benefit her in
her way yeah she's shoot well structure
American finish we showed up chance
lactose yeah she answers the door
completely naked she just spent half the
day completely naked basically she got
all over vagina pierced while I was like
used to this is allowance and he's then
settled in her place next thank you to
do you remember what his allowance was
out of interest it depends how long it
was for little it's least like a hundred
pounds of hundred dollars a day
something like a fridge food and he's
drunk quite generous I am an endless
free drugs
it's a wages it's a weight really yeah
the job didn't really charge before and
a lot more thousands of hits I can
imagine
well I've just gotta [__] dealers
were say I collected the [__] bodies
of help so I'd go I literally [__] no
he's just being dropped off this little
handle and then I'm gonna answer both
myself give you a couple of [__] you
packed with you when it comes to click
there I'll just saw said I was showing
wall needs a [__] know
[Music]
Cody Bates
you gotta claim this money before while
mouth shows up at this point
[Music]
[__] tear my boys
all right so you guys see a face and
they're funny you know for the bank you
know it was just like so normal right
I love the dog say the dog should comb
fuckingly face yeah yeah you saw her a
weird soft friendship then yeah yeah
yeah yeah a lot of them just a well man
as the protector
yeah the teddy bear that but also the
[__] mean come on you need it yeah
yeah yeah that works in our favor me I
gotta get so that was good what next
sentence
she's alright so did you run that end of
the ground the way you did the rest of
them or did that work no I was right
when she said I'll [__] tear them she
did yes he's walking the dogs she was
fun right yeah she was the only person
everything while mine ended up leaving
voluntarily and she didn't actually move
out of her own house
yeah she started going out with G dog
didn't she yeah why abloom come go over
the chicken
oh yeah showed up one time Sully wax
weilman's off his face on janux being a
sole ear except the naked just giggling
and was on the phone all the kids you
[__]
every day a tough period over freefall
caps ball of GHB it was me favorite joke
at the time really I felt like he was
kinda healthy for me as well just so
bill my soul well don't work it out now
to the entry of wild woman into the
criminal acts yeah right like he's a
muscle relaxant mmm the whole idea of my
dad sat behind it was when he got to the
gym and he would be [__] doing
everything he could sleep it would help
the muscles grow so he was like almost
forced his body honey said when he'd
stayed awake on it there would be like
he would be off useful Udall money
workout ha yeah and say okay I'm
relaxing this body's muscles relaxing
and that's the got was the theory behind
it but he said my dad was old like a
loft he's taking everything you could
ever [__] imagine lady Inanna me yeah
he really took a lot yeah his favorites
yeah
if you drink on it really messes you up
I think that's why it got made illegal
someone run over a cop when they were on
GHB in Oklahoma genuinely there's a
[__] video of me as a kid like why
did my dad of like anyway so you move in
with him and you move out of that place
anything particularly notable happen in
that time all the word the arrival of
wild woman yeah yeah the missus comes
with kids so can you give us I could
correct the description of what she was
like why does she look oh well woman oh
she ended up getting called wild woman
for pretty separate reasons to me she
was all over me
Suzanne mock 13 14 years older than me
so like so wasn't just cause she was
your missus she's the wild ones
she was call while she was living Wow
because why she got caught is because
she was in a pulp and she
big girl big glass and she got colic is
there's a some woman on started saying
self into it and make [__] she ended
up having a [__] [__] fight with it
and then the family tried to join in the
daughter's coming so she fill them in
two and then for the American people
filled in means smashed or whatever are
you know sick it's a sleighing for them
was that your usual you know like when
terms of what kind of women you waiting
for
did you have a physical you know like
the right fat [__]
god bless up can't say that but many
times I am saying I look at God 60 bad
or [__] look over there get [__]
the shank an artery with a knife or a
sharp knife like in a bread knife
whenever she gotta be [__] out right
you got a workout Washington what was
the worst injury just this is a little
will come back this what's the worst
injury you've ever occurred in a fight
generally was like just generally like
her most that you thought [__] I'm in
trouble here um I don't know how to
worry like that are you did she brought
me know was a couple of times I see that
was so on the songs on the phone she's
all sockets were birds and she got the
farmer had set bench smashed me in the
face with a [__] her all
don't you remember when we were like
with all those waivers on that what can
be raised well well nuns come over right
well woman's come over and he's like
having a Barney wave and he's like come
on let's go collecting debts line
shooting pool and I've got this like
laid-back guy who's got this pad and
it's always got beautiful raver chicks
over there giving him massages and stuff
so we go over there under water bet
getting these massages there from all
these beautiful raver girls and didn't
you accidentally leave the phone turned
on a pocket dad think me amateur amateur
I'm disappointed this whole time she
hood I've made someone getting a car and
said take me [__] over done
right so she can here you go yeah yeah
starving it makes me sad and she didn't
see the funny side of it
smut read the [__] juice along spins
the book in me okay I don't suck at all
he'll know you expect the gay sailing I
mean I'd do is out of push you I'll give
it a [__] slap that's all you could
just have a [__] stab me oh she's
[__] it me was a fold oh yeah oh
she's trying to [__] take me in I
don't even Scavo I'll be [__] Network
she's come up he was [__] broomstick
pool cue forget everything right she was
like she had the same sample it is me
and that's the nature of the
relationship relationship it was a very
stupid can I just say I feel sorry for
the naked girls cuz
[Music]
so if you're quite high and you see her
steamy massage I wonder what she's doing
there know what's coming you spiked the
redundant you as well yeah well he
cannot say the Canseco is ready pills
you could take all these ease but you
should never give me LSD because what's
the one of us stay in a very dangerous
man
put fox5 LSD and he's looking to exhale
dangerously was like a little [__]
girl this is from what I remember cuz
we're with Walmart yes yeah you're on
the come-up now still you're here at
yours men for the others they look up
ROTC or they happy while woman's turned
up yeah how was that all working out
generally aside from the fact that
you've beaten [__] out of everyone
so I established them in Tempe now a
wild woman is like becoming a bailar
and so she good good at that like cuz
she was good at it yes I left it for the
city girl and I forgive left her why she
was the famous see watchable there
wasn't healthy and the titty girl was
yes so she became one of your dealers
yeah so one minute wild woman's doing
good the next minute
in a fight and he's moved out and I
thought the back the only federal tries
to drop it right yeah yeah we do
totally now so she becomes one of your
main guys ago yeah things are quite
volatile with were the two of them but
then well man is walking down the street
one day and he said something to a woman
and a policeman overheard it and didn't
liking and that's Wellman to show him
his ID and while mother fake ID in the
name of candy HOF you just pulled it out
and showed the policeman this high tea
that said candy roof hold it well lastly
you know that's that's true well not see
a fake ID what that moon was would be
into the driving yes and actually went
and got the IDs so it's real looking so
no it's a real this a real ID yeah but
what happened is this was driving people
were you going from and that's the
[__] up the woman behind me was called
candy off so I don't know how but
they've got my name they've got my face
but with her name and with her ID it'll
be [__] earth face with my [__]
name right it was an actual real ID but
that was the end of his cells there I
was being number second stakes to please
the rest of me federal false ID I no no
no no he's in deportation prison for a
year what was that like it was alright
at two-thirds a lot better it was like I
go in the kitchen there especially
because you're not really a prisoner in
deportation no you're not you're
clusters of prisoners get ematic really
isn't it yeah it's like what I mean yes
three courses it got sold a machine it's
like couldn't make who chose oh and
obviously no one there is really no no
you to be in the baddest [__]
thereby accompany my voice is biggest
you know excuse really things like this
right but I think you met some no
because there's that like did have
different after Mexicans and
did after the chinos which is like that
the Chinese and basically when they met
I don't know what it was rhythm did you
go [__] local one another did fight
but he's something you on may having
ellos on either side without the didn't
bother me right didn't like adjusted me
all thing in there really I'll let one
in the kitchen and side cooking side
preparing meals without getting cast
races and most of the things I'll end up
going in the kitchen because an awful
fact that I can make my own food and
it's gonna be better than what they make
yeah and it's like you get paid for it
and plus I can get me yeast I can get my
stuff for me other things I want to do
for the made sense maker there is a side
thing people have asked us to ask you
about prison cooking oh yeah
why it's got some a new video yeah oh
yeah yeah it's well it's just I mean if
you taste prison food you'd start making
your own food me dad used to do the same
thing that was a period he went the
cooking prisons yeah you stay off if you
know you're getting your own food you
reckon you know you're getting you
getting fresh actually getting you fresh
food and hot who will you make me feel
the places I mean a society may actually
for the job which is spent in there god
knows what goes on in it but when you're
making your own food that goes in the
tray and this you sat there in ages
no I mean you might get it lukewarm but
it's not to say when you actually work
in the kitchen you get your own and you
have benefits work in the kitchen the
like wilwording newcastle every everyday
you get like a snotty you get like a
[__] big [__] bomb like that and
you put it all fill in on it so it's
like yeah get in the kitchen and you
knew that see sort of got straight in
the kitchen yeah yeah so i after you got
deployed did you ever go back to that or
was this was this when things start
getting really extreme for now things
get a more extreme because while he's in
deportation prison Skinner now sees he's
out the picture and he's got nothing to
worry about and starts to plot against
me again not only that long
she's a firebomb attack with some
gangsters on wild woman's pad [__]
her
so did you hear about that yeah she with
David I wasn't with that I was still
favorite ladies obviously thank you yeah
yeah it was a digger being him yeah
because he went was living Sushant and
they at the time he was Sean's best EE
seller and then [__] wild woman style
salad and I'm not doing Gardens or
[__] make him when he feels like
himself American movie for sure and my
[__] every from where [__] well
and he's like a jealous jealous kid
really don't know me we made a
bomb-proof little in the fable yeah she
survived that
yeah it just missed that almost caught
on fire across many place on fire and
but what he did was he then had some
guys show up and offer to take her to
safety
Wow ah so technically yet right problem
reaction solution in the words of David
I yeah he he pre he was really sickening
ahead if that was actually a smart movie
organizing very smart move yeah but you
can't get one over a wild woman like
that so she said she know what the [__]
was up the church oh right away
she was like [__] you guys I don't know
you guys you could be taking me out to
the desert ain't going nowhere with you
guys
she was a head born and bred in a
pooping gassed and she was like Sally
yeah yeah streetwise yeah yeah so she
didn't go then go when this happens Oh
cuz you're the head of the [__] whole
operation yeah I don't know what's gone
down properly all I know is that she's
been fire bombed
I go down there because like I've got
this close-knit network of people and I
just start like calling people in an
interview people and asking them we know
what you think's happened there what's
gone down what have you heard
and then I found out slowly but surely
the words that are coming up that it was
Skinner and one of my strip dancer
friends he'd been at her house before
he'd done this and he'd met he'd
mentioned some stuff about fire bombs
and stuff
and that time he should have got the
desert in all first but I was in
immigration that's for car like a little
yeah but you didn't have any other
heavies about team I said oh yeah yeah
damn g-type I think G Doug was in our
prison but I don't know I had a bounces
well then Skinner turned one of my
bouncers called Vince I had Vince in
well woman's flat [__] bounce we were
shotgun anyone who came over to
Wellman's flat got greeted by Vince with
the shotgun and to make sure that she
didn't get robbed there anything they
like again but but Skinner poisoned
Vince right so I my wife and Vince went
to Germany and they're gonna pick up
some pills in Holland and they got hired
when they got there in the hotel they
slept together right and Vince was so
high he told my wife all of the stuff
but Skinner was plotting and they wanted
to enlist her against me
right yeah now she came back and she
just told me absolutely everything as in
she sat with him the alleged wife they
all of that by the way well our podcast
yeah what did you do about him cuz
really wants the people do to suffer you
kind of address them again really come
named yeah he was our yeah yeah so now
I'm paying a lawyer to expedite well
man's release because things are getting
too heavy against me now we've Sammy the
ball and all that stuff as in you you
need a buck with you yeah yeah I'm gonna
rest with the Mexican kids cookie the
Vivica - ooh that looks good did that
work that yeah yeah he came back bought
things just went mental
cuz now he's at war with Skinner
Skinner's smoking crack Sherm sticks
embalming fluid crystal meth yeah it's
like you know basically what it it's
almost like PCP you think it's when you
died you put it in your body
no I mean what does it do to you that I
know embalming fluid ears but what does
it actually do to your body you know
I never did it I never visible yeah this
year I'll never did heroin never did
needles so so skin is told Murray his
wife does we're all gonna fall down he's
done something against us and she gives
me a heads up and I'm skinny leaves town
and we don't know he's left town so well
man's at Skinner's place waiting for him
to come back to his place and I made
Joey crack shots yet so many weapons are
coming which one it was you pulled on
Joey crack how many weapons are you
having that place ready for Skinner well
that's a different place in cupboards
Lola I've never really liked guns ever
seen that guy being killed kill himself
over well suicide I never really dealt
with guns
Raghava deals in fists are there's a few
of them obviously they've got a gob of
the red or somebody know yeah but yeah
generally it was this day is [__]
asleep we just just I have like a way it
[__] bad all the music you bet the
baseball so you get out and you're
straight back into the scene and well I
can't see right now he's on Bev every
day I'm MF every day and the red dots
are kicking my goal just the red thought
something kills that's why I wanna tell
you I will hunt him down
second the desert and do you mean so
Skinner is gonna end up in the desert
Skinner school I'm trying to restrain
him trying to keep Skinner calm
Skinner's doing as many drugs as him and
it's just it's gonna explode us skin is
still dealing at this point no right so
he's basically instead life using my
name now and ripping people off say
useless years yes right boy he's a
credible threat in that he could turn us
in and that's what he did right yeah and
this is how the big police [__] he
gave the biggest insight into the
organization possible there were ten
witness statements
none of the others were insiders he was
the insider right have you not even
killed you probably would've done
yourself a [__] favor about many of us
not necessarily because that we could be
on death row yeah
so you've really got to weigh that but
he was the biggest but my ex isn't
as well the chair wildwoman yeah to
choose shop is for people agree to
cooperate with the police out of the
over 100 co-defendants in my case and I
signed a plea Baggesen no one ever had
to testify me in court and I forgive all
those people I'll never held that
against any of them but I chose those
people to work with me so I gotta take
responsibility for that respect right
the Vince was one of them Vince didn't
agree to cooperate with the police
yeah well I do want to yeah the people
who you think you know shopped you from
was one of them was Vince so Vince
didn't shock me to the police but he was
willing actually so no no he refused
really yeah even after all the [__] you
said between yourselves
yeah baby other one it cuz he's he
clearly seems like a tech broker just
whatever it's gonna benefit him I think
he did actually was dealt with I think
he did have a change of heart about
things and he was a bit scared and also
like he knows I'm connected with the New
Mexican Mafia and these guys are like
doing serious things to people was that
something that you you also knew in the
back of your mind at that time the point
where Vince got straightened out
g-dog was one of the guys who assisted
in talking to him right
see the headlines about gee dogs
brothers being these leaders of the New
Mexican Mafia doing murder-for-hire
being the most powerful dangerous mafia
in Arizona at that time just like New
Mexico and Mexico two different things
no not a New Mexico mafia right New
Mexico mafia right New Mexican Mafia
right versus the old Mexican Mafia right
so what's the difference between the new
and old like what would a New Mexico
matter new - mafia ah no ever ma okay in
the prison there's the prices than
Mexican nationals and the Chicanos who
are Mexican Americans and there are
actually at war yeah right so the New
Mexican Mafia yeah the descended from
Mexico they're in there so you've got
your old school and then you got your
youngsters coming up and they're gonna
want to take over you know just out of
interest like obviously they never did
this and you know connected with that
but like what kind of things would these
people do but New Mexican Mafia yeah
well I was like okay so say it's done
sound like a mixed egg now tonight but
19 I found out who they were you know G
dogs click but with G talk four years no
he's a budding bodyguard and stuff and I
talk G dog back home to his brother's
house one night and the whole
neighborhood was blacked out and the
police are out on the streets they're
guiding the traffic with light ones and
we pull up to G dogs brother's house and
they're all coming out in cuffs and US
federal SWAT team are bring him out if
we'd have got there a little bit early
we would have been in the SWAT team aid
so that night it was New Mexican Mafia
heads of them rounded up pictures of all
the guys who whose house we've been
going in and it said they're the most
powerful dangerous criminal organization
in Arizona at this time do you
assassinate in witnesses tried to
assassinate the head of the prison
system going after judges police was the
prison system privatized at that time it
was it oh yeah yeah someone private
summer state at that time yeah so yeah
these guys are absolutely deadly so
suffer they doing to people because in
Mexico you hear of terrible things
happening in Mexico was it similar to
that where they just be taking people
out their car shooting them or torturing
them
there was one of the hit men when I
first got introduced to them I didn't
know this guy was hitman shoved his coke
in my face he's like take this coke you
know to show that I wasn't a cop or
anything remember parking yeah so these
guys were really really hardcore yeah
yeah you couldn't mess I mean I was
terrified of it someone went inside that
place they look like me like they wanted
to eat me they loved you know not
necessarily the only time they loved me
was one night they said we're having a
party we're bringing out women over
we're gonna get high on your a and I
took them to E I got a call in middle
night saying they'd run out eat could I
bring some more a over and I arrived
they're all smiling sweating picking me
up
England man we love your ecstasy and
that was the only time they ever smile
that must felt quite good it's getting
scary it exactly the same
yeah yeah right they never I never ever
saw them again like that again after
that yeah so back to your list yeah so
wild woman was a woman to testify
against you this is laughter we all get
arrested yeah yeah yeah you you
mentioned earlier and I'm just thinking
like because she was one of your people
and although she's willing to turn on
you yeah as much as you are in in the in
the business of looking after number one
you you begin to trust people yeah what
does it feel like when you know
someone's wanted to [__] you that badly
in the beginning of an emotional
reaction have been overturned what is
that motion reaction you just think you
know this person his wants to send me up
the river for the rest of my life
basically because I wasn't ever gonna go
prison I was facing the maximum 200 year
census so I don't think you know thought
these people know everything about me
you know and the prosecutes they play
mind games
I forgive their if they like
car service because it's the fact that
choose to stab you meet you yeah I know
you're a very forgiving person my son's
I know but it's the fact that it's the
way the prosecution played mind games or
saying things of all modern women and
the choose to start bringing about the
you'll never see your kids again you
know that you never see your mom they
play emotional games yeah and you can if
I mean if you're gonna bring you a
female into your organization and [__]
hits the fan and they've got kids 99% of
them are gone and so because they
actually have to pressure point yeah
yeah it's a miracle your [__] walk
and the strip sight doesn't it what do
you think about it logically yeah [__]
your oh yeah well the prosecutors play
these mind games because they like used
car salespeople at the end of the day
the business the justice system is a
business model they want you to sign a
plea bargain ninety-eight percent of the
cases in Arizona go to plea bargains so
they put this pressure on me put this
pressure on her and in the end you know
we cower down we signed these plea
bargains which is that makes you got
mine down to nine and a half years Wow
yeah so was that a private lawyer so
let's sort of rewind a little bit on the
build-up to the eventual day way to kick
your [__] doors in in to come and get
you
yeah where are you well you don't even
on even combat yet for the other side so
let's let's go back with it to the
return of busy season this is like this
final round for now all right let's get
them up then how's life going for Sean
right now Sean
I always come up with like the kills did
you because Shawn is making so much
money right now
yeah sure net by the looks of it she'll
never change no so you two are still the
same friends
in the core of it that you always were F
culture right so where were you
he's sobered up now but he's ready for
his next fresh round yeah so you weren't
you weren't but England yeah yeah and
I'm thinking that at this point should I
really go back
it's wild woman still in it in any US
yes you're you're on you are you on your
own in England what you love it it's
just quite ridiculous isn't it so what's
happening with what where's your life
what he's bought in England things going
wrong in my organisation Newton I'm also
doing way more drugs than I've ever done
in my life so my decision-making process
is out the best I'm paying private
lawyer now to try and get him out to get
MD point and that my thing is the
lawyers like yeah we're gonna I'm gonna
expedite this he's gonna get deported
any day and as soon as he does now I'm
putting all my money into teams of
people now the game back to come back to
America they want to stay back a witness
for the whilst we fail yeah very nice
yeah no you must have went from an
insane lifestyle to little old witness
yeah happens to be in such a contrast
what was the like perfect what's the
flight back like from America
like you because I've heard of other
people being sore towards the ball
because you've chained up right there
that I've guards with me will happily
flew me back so you not see I mean when
the lady comes and actually frittering
you can have one right because you got
like yes they just coughed up and then
what happens is when you finally get to
Heathrow day guard you have to play
on coffee and then we give you to the
the officers and what have a day
well-disposed that they're like guy to
you now or arrest you if you've got any
previous to preview so whatever but i
but i basically just got through on this
one
they had no previous what happen was the
guy that double dissection 18 he'd ended
up [__] [__] up himself and being
a burglar and like [__] nothing
really happened and it was within this
like a seven year there was a seven year
thing anyway
Wilda capacity broke bring any charges
but I hope you know yeah so I'm back I'm
actually in England now and no I'm not
with wild woman no I'm back in [__]
England and I'm back at my dad's and I'm
thinking girls would not ride while
another ring but then it's you fee he
calls me back you're nothing I'll
[__] Allah you must have missed him
you must have missed officially like a
ball in the air you weren't at all
strike me the powers if if you know I
know for five you like me over there's
gonna be hassled yeah it's a Mexican
seems of people back into the country
because the first time is a greyhound
were you in just in the storage of a
greyhound or what no
a flu from God a fluted surround so
Canada right and I went over the border
from Canada
it's a Buffalo New York and then from
New York have got the greyhound it sucks
freakin half days she threw him
greyhound I will said that so he was the
guy the guy who picked me up said you
want to get the plane I saw the [__]
that I just like for could beat all
around the world so get back in the
country I don't wanna get the last thing
I wanna do is get over playing Hillary
so like what could he like me on said no
I get the gray and I get the coach you
must have seen well I didn't realize how
big it [__] was yeah funny cuz when
English people go to America don't think
they realize how big I was like that cuz
in England when you do that with your
fingers you're like ask three hours
maybe $2 in America and you do that on
the map that's like that that's a day
you know what I mean
do you lipstick all from jelly gross the
buns end in a day in England yeah I'm in
America yeah [__] drive must have
been amazing it was nice but Dulli bad
thing about it or if you're loves
traveling deal argus know about
greyhounds an artbook they always seem
to off the station and it's about a mile
away from any Circle K or a mile away
from anywhere you can all get [__]
beer right so hard you can actually get
it so like it somali or [__] whatever
fast-food together and you haven't even
got time to go and get yourself some
beers' 12 on the course on the next
journey so you literally feed half days
you're going and I think I missed one of
them one else to pay extra to so I'm not
doing this not getting on college I got
12 back for em late [__] though what
can you do yeah so you but you then make
your way across the country but you see
lots of things yes we dramatically
eagles of things you see beautiful
things you know you do see those things
this is all a movie montage isn't it
like a man on a coat are you not a wild
by that exactly no no I genuinely this
whole [__] thing like this whole
thing's amazed me just absolutely numb
right now you know
just the thing is when when you guys
talk I always sort of like I sort of
picture everything in me exactly yeah so
you then arrived in Arizona you're back
in the heat the baking heat would desert
does he greet you yeah you're not there
when he gets up the coach I mean you
will be in the movie yeah bringing him a
coordinate you know and he gets there
and I update him on what's going on and
things got a bit hot for the Wild Ones
then in Tempe while woman's place got
raided no I'd rented her a place and I
also rented her place next to the place
just as a store of drugs in in case she
got raided but she got raided and the
traumas actually got back by the way by
there as well you got together yeah we
got back together right and Salazar
volatile is New Mexico together didn't
we so why are things get so hot now well
a man's going berserk wants to take skin
out to the desert wild woman's got
raided she's good so I get more moving
with that just make sure she's on fire
no Impala again things I asked some
about with this Easter find much more
melons our just constant saying I'm
[__] getting high and wants to kill
Scully that was my thing he wants to do
it's really think al Skinner
yeah come back to this do anything cool
bastard whom she fails to do so
she's been regret I raided with
thousands of hits of ecstasy acid meth
ketamine xanax assorted Mexican pills
and they just let it go yeah yeah they
said to her she said she said she was
just in that place this find us as this
pod
all right she doesn't cooperate it would
have been in the paperwork shut it so
you told that they like or as a lead bit
yeah yeah she told them she's got she's
dating some English guys on four
nominees he's put her in this apartment
but she just wants to go home blah blah
blah and they just lived they said well
if you find out anything about them if
you want to tell us anything else you
know is is
well the detective who he was where
nemesis yes yeah yeah detective Reid
yeah call him breathe
he was totally on to us so it's easier
for him really to release her Yeah right
no now I will come back for all the way
from ok with this back again it'll be
[__] super that's too bad because I
knew it would have been trouble yeah I
knew for the fact they also do is watch
where she goes ooh she's mixing with
what's going on and tail Allah so you
something the big parties at this point
are you two still going out and you know
it's like it's like each paranoid yeah
everyone's get a bit paranoid at this
point no my idea was that yeah no that
way when you're in it no because you
just your brains like all messed up and
you're just thinking I can get keep I'm
going to sustain this somehow
so people I say now my next grand scheme
is because I've got operations in Mexico
it's got so big now my pills gotta get
smuggled in through Mexico my thing now
is to move the wild ones to Mexico and
all the mates say the way they behave if
while man acts up in Mexico the Mexicans
will kill him right send them down their
web web this ad this guy was a military
sniper spot Mexican Frankie flowers send
send you down there Frankie flowers and
Emma Marie and man Cody is also dead
course we can say his real name yeah
they ran in this nice house in Rocky
Point so doesn't the telecommunications
are quite problematic so I'm not in
contact with the wild ones but I'm
sending people down there with supplies
now my guys go down and supplies Cody
went down there with supplies and he
arrives and the house is completely
looks like it's been bombed the windows
are blown out
fire and he comes back says the Mexicans
have killed well ones it's done it's
over so I've got a sent Frankie flowers
back down that on a research trip my
over made skirts go by down II thought
he was gonna get killed to get to the
bottom of things
why were you what happened this is the
people who top meanwhile them down with
too keen we went out for a meal and ice
he'd give him the money so golf fine
there's a place will give me the money
to go family all [__] place give him
the photo in the end the [__] you have
to look around all day in the end they
get cliff to this [__] guy say look
I'll give you the money all those
[__] names it's my [__] money you
know I'm not kidding you know my ending
it so I grabbed a few ground off him and
[__] we found the [__] place so
meanwhile we're [__] the rocky point
it was like that the time to rebuilding
it up it's not so no they're not sure
maybe a but any rate not not much more a
senora so will where that will go
driving this dirt [__] rolled up
there and they've got like little houses
here and little shacks here and there
and there's a bar for the broad day oh
the yeah yeah so we ended up going in
the bar meanwhile a woman got this
little place those hoes got a couple
grand in the pocket fine no remains may
have some he's in the back whatever
don't bother on parking just slow the
bike lanes and there's a buyer open the
Jets and it's jillybear around there who
know me say son juice and all eyes you
know it's called Rocky Point so go there
I'm seeing these big huge [__] birds
it was a [__] hello there so many
these fish tacos these like big pelican
thing comes and [__] sacks a key for
me around no you got Blackpool and you
get the big bears these are like [__]
these are all sterilized these [__]
don't our punch water comes now like
I'm sorry get closer dig it
yeah she's like Toby
oh this Pelican dude who's Sonny be food
just the two of you this point yeah yeah
there are kids with a dad not with the
dad I with a husband an ex-husband
AEM he fought for custody or something
realized that he didn't want I didn't
want them over there which hope you
understand I know there isn't enough to
be fairly short on me earlier but anyway
so we sat there there were a few bears
chilled you know you know in Mexico over
a different place no [__] noses few
grand in the pocket goes a long way you
makes it go so I'm thinking all right
yeah finally now we can be laughs I go
back to the place al had a few beers
I don't want kick it off oh I bought the
bottle ski way and stayed under the keel
and I was a [__] that just normal
cigarette no join and she says don't
smoke in the house [__] off along with
the [__] house why should you stand
up say another [__] well you don't know
if it's a non-smoking or not we don't
want to offend him we were just gonna
yeah I saw the what - were having a
[__] [__] which is paid on one foot
[__] from for god sake no I mean cut
a long story short she starts [__]
arguing so a [__] in a flick in this
book and she throws her shirt at me
that's it she's also cherry it's a
reasonable debate so absolutely yes
you're single okay there we go again we
had a [__] they even baby dad's house I
mean what the [__] you never come back
yeah so I'm just feeling I'm just
waiting on this wicked scale of thinking
you didn't top you you [__] just
looking for [__] struggle and she's
like man and not even largest [__] off
just go back to the bar to every [__]
he won't go so she carries on carries on
and I know flick if I gotta say pick
that up [__]
just being an ass and [__] has that
happened the whole [__] floor so I
went below and then before it going like
seconds after the web blew the wind just
went the windows all popped
well that's the Apple to shoot food at
sure and hit the fireplace right and
only Mexico doll over there we have like
copper pipes for gas over there it's
plastic rights just crack the [__]
pipe gas coming out guys let's have it
yes yes so the whole place is unfair the
windows have just popped out the whole
place is on fire
so here yeah so she's really round with
the frying pan so I'm gonna get water
trying to pull it out I get a fine I see
some movement there this side Noah
really story though
so this dragon sickly soft cow you know
so jagged I said go find the neighbors
from it so she really brought Scouts
knocking on Mexican people's doors try a
shelf cider and tell them a fire fire
fire they like to just [__] like what
not comprehend a look at the lilies
alright but in the end she's plating you
see flame throughout [__] door so do
fall the fire brigade so I'd love to eat
Mexican fire brigade by the way oh my
god building bed right 20 minutes by the
way I'm behind you [__] taxes yeah
and the guys forgive the guy next door
panicking she's got a really nice speedo
in the [__] yeah right next to this
[__] like combo you're awake
it's a nice place excuse me
so so unlock your thoughts [__] it you
always and I see this thing coming up
and it's like a little old [__]
stroke I swear to god there's three
people on it
there's no joke this God's honest truth
ready to go straight be dead now there's
two guys on the back one spoke the wrong
way one spoke the other way and once all
the nose is coming out in spurts
it's this [__] ring the first day
you're there you wanna jump now set the
house on fire
yeah and you're standing outside in
Mexico it wasn't really that they're
being bombed obviously then this is just
the first house this is the first house
to go like that right see you're
watching this you thinking all I'm
thinking is there is something
incredibly exciting about all this but
it must have felt so exhausting at that
time it was just some just mundane of
those it's just a pointer it's like it
got to the point of being normal yeah
you know they're just bizarre she's
gotta know what and that must feel
almost like a curse in a way it was why
did I come back here you could have been
in witness disrespecting witness but
relatively unexcited towards things I
yeah you could have been drinking so
much [__] less stress killed yeah to
you witness is like a [__] holiday
right now whereas originally it was
supposed to be aware of and that is
pretty much testament how mental your
life was really without problems because
his bird got [__] so [__] he calls
me but right and but like I said that's
Testament that bad no that was one of
the many propositions is testament to
the fact that your life was so intense
and crazy at that time yeah and you're
sucking other people into that life yeah
I'll we don't really want to be there
but it's you you think you're doing them
a favor by taking them there yeah and
that's your crazy mentality that exactly
is that you want them there cuz you care
about them yeah
but [__] it like you're ruining their
lives while you're doing it and you
along with your own
I don't say that in a mean way there's
something quite poetic about the two of
you and then you stuck out in the middle
of nowhere midden water pumping so what
do you do Michael do a wall forgot today
was going there and get the clothes
right so it's like a twist on the wall
I'm also an investment in that rave
clothing store then back together the
long haul dress yeah the landlord that
chose the place come down we didn't say
about without a fight or anything you
know what I mean we just said he hadn't
rented out for a month so we said we
walked into less thinking right and the
job then he's gone up and he's done what
are you saying speaking Spanish and I'm
not the Quito now but I did not say
anything to the side so it was like
basically he houses about 100 years down
the road but got all close go away of
his [__] shipment supply so how long
was this between the end well there's
still quite a few little things before
the very height this is just the first
house he destroys [__] America in Mexico
yeah I was the first one he was running
the place right he said they would kill
him he flicked up these Mexican Mafia
thirds who clicked with the police
doesn't me running round and jeeps and
stuff taking me places wanted to get a
business relationship going
well you and I see Mexican Mafia they do
pythons they're like real Mexicans
Chicanos are American Mexican the pace
ons are Mexican Mexican right so the day
after all they after all my like the New
Mexican Mafia they have to click this is
like these like all Mexico linked into
the cartel tradition yeah not obviously
not Italian mafia but that you know like
more of those they had more of a
hallmark of
as known as Mexico Arizona model called
exactly a Mexico Arizona border is a
major hub for the cartels to get their
drugs in so all these guys they are
allied with a certain cartel sing a lot
of cartel offical yeah yeah hey sweetie
brings me over who have all good
intentions and just puts me a early
tells me oh we've decided to change
route now allowed the pills according to
Mexico so that's why I'm [__] me no
say they'll say yeah so for the goodness
it's not the worst place to pay them
realistically danger wise and in terms
of anything can happen see down there no
one will give a [__] the police will do
it for you yeah yeah but he was eat all
right you got ripped off on a crack deal
so I've relocated and now it's this
beachfront condo of renting it through
this guy in our Mesa beautiful property
you know right there on the Sea of
Cortez he goes and buy some crack gets
back to the condo looks at the crack
rock and he's not happy about this crack
right what happened there lad those
suits well I thought for the [__]
price I gave him wasn't it bunk as well
as something well the proper sound but
it's just like for kiddie Mexico you
expect a big [__] rock filled your
own dollars like so I've got a guy let's
get this in perspective outside guy yeah
he'll know I'd be off basically so bring
your cherry
I've got a guy bringing in 40,000 hits
of ectasy right now in computer towers
from Mexico City is - already flew over
from Europe to Rocky Point where
warehouse
I want everything as calm as possible
right now no please attend you shouldn't
tell me this though and he's like I'm
gonna go on [__] this crack dealer up
because I've just been ripped off on my
crack rock and I don't care if it's a
[__] dollar or a thousand not a
hundred thousand nobody [__] rips me
off my [__] red dots are [__]
telling me to go and hurt this
[__] and I just can't calm him
down
so I say all right I'll Drive up there
and drop you off I'm coming right back I
mean ain't getting involved in the mix
because I've got all these pills coming
so he goes those the dude and he's
talking to the police the police is
right next to him like [__] piss off why
let's just go he's like no just pull up
slowly and I'll get out so I pulled up
slowly and he did this kind of timing
violence strike as he's not quite out of
the vehicle yeah Klunk Klunk them
against a lamppost so he said you swam
[__] he fell down unconscious and the
police I I take off I'm now I'm saying
to everybody in the apartment you did
this right in front the police a girl
called he is some money bail him out at
the police station this you know
hopefully this won't attract too much
attention what you knew the police see
you things over though you get to forget
the doctors like little apart from the
federales if you face it around there
they treat you as a [__] local so you
buy him some Saturdays there's some
bears and all a lot because they don't
know money no I mean the local general
places a little money he that's it
another [__] of Jamie's here and I
got some wells there for a while I got
to know the local businessmen there who
are hanging in the quads and all that
and they were friends with the school
with these police and all that so I'm
sat there [__] doing caught a [__]
smoking joints and these [__]
policeman coming and they sit down
others and that's how unknown and this
[__] guy a clonk policeman what was
looking I didn't know this as it sounds
he throws
as well as the guy I met from [__]
Alex's place we didn't [__] say
anything right yeah say you you've
pretty much bought yourself immunity
there yeah yeah you ingratiate yourself
into these communities goes we took him
to Hollywood Boulevard one of those
dodgy pink hotel rooms and we all went
to a rave and when we came back all the
street people were knocking on the door
of every five or ten minutes it's Peter
there you know we've got some free drugs
free and they were giving him the street
people were giving him free drugs all
night long the whole time we would uh
some dude in a viper car with key within
the other kilo of coke trying to get
well months of Spain Oh stay leave
Austin just go off with him into the
night I mean all tell me I've never
thirty thousand [__] knees next door
something else I'll do it and in the
[__] right next rich sunset bills are
that was Hollywood this guy called pulls
up in a viper and suitcase gets our kids
through I've got a few pills on me in a
bear glass I didn't want to go other day
if it did fancy it I thought it just put
me in this old seleya this [__]
rockers on the street all looking fit
[__] you've got money was working pocket
in the [__] hour gonna [__] party
was the party people zero meeting
tonight people God's I could swim oh
this is so gay I suppose all these
[__] eruption full so we end up
[__] smoking crack about a while they
tells me here's the keys to the car go
down and get me such as such so the car
passes a favourite of sat there thinking
I could steal this thing I can [__]
drive sort of sat there thinking
starting from the way of thinking not
cats there's a lot so used to looking
very right back upstairs usable he keys
and we'll the [__] you whatever he wants
it for the [__] cash I was thinking I
could steal this down then it's just an
realization so I can't [__] drive you
come on so you can put him anywhere in
the world
and it'll all the local people at the
night will start respecting him they'll
gravitate yeah they gravitate towards me
starts running any area he will start to
run the area it's the accent but yeah I
don't bully on anything should I get on
with people or vaquita I'll have a lot
of strangely you're a people person
ah yeah very much so people who love
dogs should rather kill a person than a
dog yeah yeah so he's not that guy out
you don't have to pay any cops off at
that point
yeah the pills come we get him back and
that was the last big smuggling mission
that succeeded in the app with
organizers after then it was it was
downhill someone else pills got Jack
then we we brought well men and some
weather guys back over the border to try
and sort that situation out and things
just started to go downhill rapidly
didn't mean well also the Mexico thing
with the cops did you let things slide
we've made bhakti videos openly at one
point well man in the end because why
had I lost a smuggler this guy out of
Mexico he got popped coming back in and
in Mexico City with some ecstasy from
Europe and his mum was connected
politically yeah she in in Rocky Point
and she saw it with them that people in
power wouldn't let wild man stay
anywhere and he ended up forgetting
smuggle back over into Arizona
so she chase you're out of town really
yes you change me on sound but not only
that the police kind of in the way
because everything's all good for the
little sheep things without get drunk
and for a couple he wouldn't do anything
about he's buying the way if you got
down there and you [__] up always just
have like a hundred dollars or fifty
dollars in you shot and no matter what
it is really come up like a cold yeah
whatever just give him that and I got
above the year but what that's the
happen was I'm certain victors the guy
here is the quartz the same please come
in who saw him a little after them now
they mentioned they basically say we
know where you don't say we know what
you're doing
and if you pay us a certain amount we'll
make sure that your [__] remember your
[__] gets from one place to another
something is [__] I was like Starkey
Denis in the way
mmm because you know and if you [__]
know to go back you can have it's a icky
oh yeah pay up or you're [__] relief
exactly Mexico they have an area called
the plaza and whoever's in charge of
that plaza the police whatever drug
you're dealing through that plaza you
have to pay the police and they'll
arrest your competition and secure you
that area for you they're gangsters
they're just yes the eyes are very
different yeah there's the gang of
please the biggest market that's often
said yeah yeah I've heard a lot of
people say [__] like that
no the federales you please they don't
give no forage okay oh just shoot you're
on they working the child cells like an
army for the cards yes all right they go
down in mini tanks to dress all in black
could we go round like that little mini
[__] tanks which we've what at least
some locals are we get paid Sorry Sorry
moans phone the police the locals and
the other you paid much [__] money
yeah so whatever [__] job 50 or 20 or
whatever the charge it the tourists what
coming there because you've got spring
break is coming Rocky Point megistus
it's a from Monday to Thursday waves
[__] yeah it's like one of them places
where you see like [__] you know them
Dutch Swedes [__] blowing food for
big break and I've gone fried you sadly
saw these people come down and then you
got spring break
you got yards over spring break you got
yellow Spring Break member sallyboyd
nearly got arrested down there because
she's got a dyke triangle going on a
procession on a procession all that all
the University students at them on
spring break this like truck itself it
comes comes by
comes we're all this cheer and all these
cheer Lobster Sally wax doing the dyke
triangle on this truck well then the cop
started freaking out yeah I'm just
thinking if they ever make a movie out
of your life I want to play a wild man
[Music]
that's my goal
yeah make me debut Lawrence Canterbury
I'll happily direct I was worried you're
gonna give me [__] roll they just made
like one of those just a quick
appearance in the movie as one of the
crack people in the background so what a
big gun tits up we're so far I think we
need another episode to be honest but
when we should do the present one in the
X that Prasad I'm just finishing this
one's gonna be almost three hours yeah
when it went tits up what were you
thinking because you were you in Arizona
when it was easy
alright he's gotta be smuggled back now
in Arizona yeah he's back he's back I've
got teams of people again wait you know
trying to get him across the border
try Arizona try California's not working
it's not working
she forgets he was one of them spies are
the gives him flats a living I was
learning like 20 different more novels
for people money gives me [__] jobs
apartments everything how long did you
get when they all wanted so openness me
yes yeah actually I ended up doing the
most out of them all [__] cuz he's been
deployed twice baby planets were
slightly by the judge
sandy sellers most sites it was a legal
fall so I ended up gained eight years
and I did that seven and half of them
today for the right okay and then I did
like a year being
right but you haven't discussed the
houses then beyond four houses that get
destroyed yet house mom's gone
whatever its cigarettes and gas it was
its own fault yes this guy owes me money
right Oh is DJ yeah so basically can't
repay whaleman's moving in commissary
sorry I think you got beyond the army
but I'm not thirty forty ground
something like that so wild man's gonna
move in that's a punishment let's get
back before girls a story like Ella got
back from Mexico okay
so [__] it works out this coin sets
up got the police ask you for [__]
money to bring in all the big pills in
and we used this [__] influential
[__] [__] some who [__] ended
up we sent him to go [__] get some
pills the Duff bastard [__] put him
in socks and like [__] got high with
the girls or not what means I had a
personal supply in his socks
yeah bulk yes yeah bookies got high with
the girls and Amsterdam and he was that
[__] off his head that she walk you
through the earth for [__] pills up
and through his own supply all the back
so they lost him and then his [__]
math it was like all [__] to hide and
most people it's like caught like coal
and me feel like [__] getting some
arrested and [__] cuz he's looking at
god knows what I mean or he's bending
you exactly yeah right so eventually
Sean gets me out of there and it was i
remembers up the day was it was the day
before 9/11
September 10th 2000 more new left
okay the day before yeah yeah because I
know that for fat because of thoughts
itself if it had been any time after I
don't never got [__] no hmm because
the security show realized and it was
just like you go over the border and
they don't even [__] actually
anything you got how many college kids I
mean you understand from Tucson it's a
rocky potent word of what you think
Mexico is big but we already talked
about enough is it yeah it's right there
on the border floors go for it yeah you
just mix it up a column say dude
literally ourselves spoons of it is just
out of interest you would smuggle drugs
when's the ideal time to smoke smuggle
drugs across the corner yes so when it's
like spring break when does the yep not
many was looking for tips but yeah
that's the best place to do it
well best so but really the best I was
never to do it yeah I respect your body
you get back across the border just
pretend to be a student or whatever
exactly yeah and you're back in Arizona
yeah things are [__] up for him at
this point things are getting crazy now
he's a he's at war with Skinner again
he's getting on so much math and I was
the only time I ever got scared of wild
man was meeting Righetti were in the
front seat of a car wild man's on the
back seat Donna what weapons he's got on
his person and I look in the mirror and
I just see these mad dog eyes looking at
me all bloodshot he's he's that he's
I've been on Murph and he's not slept
for about five days I was annoyed that
he ever didn't do nothing about [__] his
curly and he goes and he starts looking
at me and he's like haha
I know you two guys are taking me out to
the desert right now and I'm like my
Twitter to be fair you've got those eyes
to heaven yeah you've got he's got I
though those
Luca Brasi like that that's what yeah
yeah yeah you look a broad size of light
yeah a killer so he's never ever sports
me like this before and I'm thinking
[__] hell is he gonna snap while I'm
driving and do something like what about
what you love about lying it cost you
just sketching you just go math why
would we do that cuz I know too much so
he's laughs grown in America this is
what he's like now he's gone to this
level her annoyed us [__] yeah well
woman said he was pacing in this place
they were living out he had weapons all
over the place and she was like what's
the problem what's the problem Oh [__]
Johnson in the Mexicans because I know
what's goin on the Mexicans are coming
they've got wood-paneled cars I know
exactly what cars they're driving so
he's just completely gone into this over
dimension now and now I'm trying to like
keep em calm trying to keep everybody
else I'm stalking these Mexicans it
would be worth the gapless right but the
police please so hot on to me my lawyer
now says basically you got a spot this
is to [__] on too far are you [__]
you've got a good run stop I'm with the
woman I'm with I'm in love with she
talked me out the dealing now that last
big mission was the last big one
so I'm winding everything down now and
while I'm in a while game of you pardon
will be for you yeah it feels like if
you'd carried on at that rate when they
did come we got a new dive in the we
haven't solved in when we you it's too
late now innit it's a while man a wild
woman now I'm not got the supply of
drugs anymore so they're on a rampage
now of ripping off all of the dealers
they can get possibly get free drugs off
which is creating more mayhem because
they use in your name yeah
yeah and what was the bit why you ended
up throwing boulders through the car and
the house windows and everything which
one in the air Hey not even finish the
DJ's house story yeah well that ends up
with that [__] there's two houses get
destroyed you there are times where I'm
sometimes I play computer games near
like this is a ridiculous story this
would never happen and then he's like
not even finish the DJ's house yet I
look at those Asher Asher put the DJ's
house
he's famous gee I can't speak well I
close it but the beat is long gone cuz
Wildman's moved in and I know the less
that the DJ thought he turned around and
old money touch the mountain money and
he's saying people have come in and
robbed us we haven't got your money sure
and we've seen a pattern of this and
this is how I knew that we had that
demise yeah whose people always gonna
collect soon so they disappeared like
now normal right don't mean you only got
the same seats on each of the [__]
right they've all got a new witness you
get that feeling where it's like what
the saying is you know yeah yeah so
either you pull that one didn't he what
did you say - when you moved in there I
said that's all fine I said well if you
got ripped off welcome a movie to make
sure you know right yeah meanwhile woman
for kids splits up again [__] news
just [__] just sick of a [__]
madness because it was just it was on an
on and off relationship all over the
walls but almost anyway she's doing
their [__] thing out didn't mind so
I'm moving this [__] place am i I'm
enjoying it and I've got some girls come
around the Sierra comes around and all
the city girl dancer gotta stay within
city girl dances you look at me I mean
they're wonderful on the army lesson and
personal views Brian
yeah I genuinely do of two years oh you
girls the rest what do you know he goes
yeah no girls who were gonna take you
boss yeah this one's Italian and she's
like actually [__] really that nice I
literally huge fateful mutates well like
do you like fake boobs I don't give a
[__] any boobs as long as the [__]
bacon fat right I want some fat really
but she was really slimming by really
good moment I barely fit all Miley yeah
I like the slap is not a sense of to is
you get outside the nightclub
I don't person them I can imagine the
exact person so you don't like your
memory
yeah back in the day you did but so how
did you get a girl like that why are you
gonna kill her at that time I just that
drugs please my charming at drunk yet
charismatic he's like a mouthy figure to
these ravers so they're thinking like
you know he's safe he's a character he's
established it's like a legend because
you're I was normal masseur when yeah I
was known I was known as Jones who
thought this time of you cuz you
something working out quite a lot sort
of not working out directly but sort of
you know using a hassle well yeah was
rocky debts and [__] and just his
behavior was intimidating enough and
there is behavior that was constant and
at this point he's in another dimension
because of all the math not sleeping
people thinking [__] you know I don't
even have to do something wrong around
him yeah it could just throw me through
a window physically fit because I didn't
[__] eat daily right as I was always
on the [__] mess you look like Dennis
Rodman at one point with the blonde yeah
so says let's lay low and you think
bleach-blonde yeah looking a little
better as well because I got all this in
prison a path for the [__] though
breaking it once but [__] it's like I
think a lot too but then I was probably
down to about what sixteen stolen at one
point yeah it was six things doth God
obviously no he's just getting berserk
on math so he's found where Skinner
lives finally this is just before we're
gonna get arrested now and he's in the
house I'm Joey crack shows up and how
many weapons the job in there that's
where the ball was coming when I woke up
the wrong [__] guy the amount of
people have suffered because you thought
it was that I mean I'm going all the way
back to the beginning way because I
could yeah
this shouldn't drive wait you sat
through the wall and he's just got this
really sad look on his face despondent
and his face is covered in soot hello
pull over them like what's happen Wilma
why do you look so sad so I can't live
there anymore ah they accidentally got
set on fire last night when I went to
sleep and what happened was wasn't my
fault it was basically a Christmas
lights it was
I didn't think [__] stubborn his
reindeers about something to do with us
this is my and I was sweetly and this
guy had moved in and he was like
computer thingies love this computer so
you left other computers so I squished
of Allah what do you don't sweet you
think you [__] do anything so I'm
like a walk in progress
oh you know you started making my
cravings will [__] sauce right you
use yourself for a couple hours you got
yourself a forgive the screws I have any
like hey that's it you just focused on
something clean that I'm big tips 60
girls right so Carlos started sure I've
got all these things plugged in and I've
got the sister girls coming so on a farm
like so [__] candles be romance it
you don't get a [__] some perfume
meal deals deal feels I'm still a dude
so [__] I'll go get these meals and
[__] you say I know I'm thinking are
yeah she wants banging in the ass
[__] that she told me jacking and
[__] do it today so I'll be nice to
get the Campbell's out there lucky girl
all the Campbell's I went all up
to HC ready drugs but off came not
tweaking anything it's we make six weeks
crystal meth yes so I ended up [__]
fall asleep upstairs there's one of them
Farnsworth it was like it was opener
who's like you go upstairs in the
bedrooms there but there's a balcony
seat down Spurs so I'm sat there for
kids that I've just slept and they
really powered up I saw I thought it was
like three I will just put really like
twelve and as I'm sleeping I'm sorry
like thinking about a Pink Floyd tree
cuz if you see like you might know like
the clouds floating over that's a good
thing so much
though foods table you see the clouds
and all this is the most modest got so
much did it son [__] resolved mommy
swath okay I think I've seen the out
says drug wash because of dollar all
reasonable and the money should have a
bag of clothes I got the clothes all
this up and they go see how close they
just go actually come by they actually
did you favor than in the long room
because he got me assurance but because
it was through so many things plugged
into the wall and it actually said face
of this [__] like what a candidate is
as out of that all the candles right now
but it doesn't open flame or the thing
that you never know will never know
these screws with a [__]
Oh screw Chavez not working it's all
[__] man see you out of another
house yeah Shawn at this point is
thinking I need to put him in a padded
cell
well the stock markets crashed so my
money has gone down rapidly now and you
depressed so about that point I would
say I was kind of like depressed and I
was doing the drugs they lost a [__]
million they'll turn the drug still
tonight counts are up should I give you
today you say and you all depress the
copper more drugs I wanted to say yeah
you were so into the drug industry at
that point the muhsinun really mattered
that much I mean so I got the deal in
and my bird was scared of me hanging out
but I was sneaking out every weekend
with wild man getting high in the GHB
and hanging out you know people of the
night you'd gone from big-time a
stockbroker big drug dealer
you've calmed down you know from the
dealing like that sort of small-time
yeah we're still quite mental and the in
terms of making money in terms of making
money in selling drugs you've got small
fight yeah boss you're still having a
fun time basically yeah it's kind of
like you've gone over that peak and it's
kind of like like clinging back to that
old legend but really you slipping
further and further down and it's
getting darker and darker the highs are
getting less and then I was doing Jade's
being just flopping on the floor like if
all the signs were there
everyone who's old saw those disappeared
and they were in town normal it was just
it didn't you and like you see like yes
to get forward a lot of the dead
giveaways I had was outside where I was
staying at pharmacist farmer Street it
was this [__] guy at the Lockport and
he's lucky he's up there like he's
acting like he's cookie fixing know what
I mean but you don't know Buster - yeah
[__] your lamppost
are you the expected service will bug in
that dollars will become so this is your
Goodfellas moment almost you know she's
like totally if anyone seen Goodfellas
at the Emmys off his face
doing the cork and that in the following
around a helicopter you feeling you're
seeing that old signs more and my guy
Cody was getting followed around by the
helicopters it's all in the police
paperwork exactly like that
yeah right yeah he was the money guy
yeah and you are getting folder we're
all doing follow so you begin to realize
this but will a cousin our
decision-making process of scrambled we
don't know if it's the police we don't
know if it's rivals you don't know if
it's just paranoia because it's just
yeah and it was often paranoia but
sometimes it wasn't and people are
telling me things and I can't I can't
now figure out whether they're paranoid
odd it is the truth be honest was it a
little bit exciting to be the number-one
target that guy no it was exciting for
me when I was at the peak of it and
everything was peaceful and I was
throwing pies up to 10,000 people I've
got the bouncers running around my
vegetables saying good luck
strip strip tease women party move them
into hotels to come up and stuff on that
was that was the excite you know that
was a scoffing so I was trying to get
back to that but it wasn't impossible so
every time you can retry you said yeah
my pit was the journey yeah yeah the
journey to that yeah just to give a [__]
around really just good times they
haven't that's a lot made that's what
life's all about
and Olivia it's Jenny I feel like we
should sort of pause just and then we'll
pick this buckle for a par four maybe
five Ewers are gonna be gagging for his
prison stories uh-uh
cuz I'm not from what you told me
there's a [__] ton of those oh man so
let's we'll just say lay it down there
all day on them and if people hit oh
yeah ten thousand likes on this yeah
we'll do it
I actually so the first time that we had
shown on the podcast I was the one who
took all the books home homicide never
read and they're very well written I put
I'll give you actual think you've really
written them on you've chosen great
stories skills and yellow will they get
better and better as you go in the
description isn't it will put Sean's
books in there well mom's playlist on
YouTube will put your YouTube plays
playlist yeah yeah yeah gotta be done
and then we'll come back for part 4 by
the way no one's ever done apart for so
I think this is worthy of let's just say
this yeah and I write we make sure and I
thought this is the mental podcast
really every podcast just keeps getting
more and more crazy but I love them
though yeah interesting people like when
you do the podcast this is like a dream
to have someone who's had such a mild
life and family yeah yes alright yeah
just absorb a feeling that should sort
of stick to certain details and many of
the details away but in the end but the
thing that's maybe you say in your
twenties you're always gonna be immortal
wild and you know there's a reason you
had an idiom and I'm sure that when we
cover all the prison stories and then
coming out and going back to regular
life yeah we'll get a different sight
you then happy married you've never been
arrested
yeah that's what normal people
yes credit used to posting all right
okay we'll pick this Paco blood okay
thanks for coming on button subscribe
thanks for watching we'll see as their
he's on camera
Oh